[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast
I am Brett Weinstein and I am sitting
here with Eric our Weinstein PhD who
happens to be my brother and I'm going
to attempt to interview him and raise in
discussion many topics on which he may
be the most interest interesting voice
that we have access to in civilization
so here goes nothing
Eric welcome to the dark horse podcast
but no pressure no pressure great to be
here on the dark earth so some people
have seen us together on occasion
episode 19 of the portal they will have
seen a discussion in which you forced me
to reveal things about my scientific
past that were little known before that
episode I have to say was a scary
episode but arguably was a more
interesting podcast of all time I would
say thanks to your your story in your
work well it was quite an adventure and
anyway I want to thank you for doing
that
it absolutely added an important
dimension to my life especially my
public life in an area where I had more
or less shelved prior work and I think
it was time that it returned we will
come back to that story later I of
course know a great deal about your
history I also find out frequently that
there are things I don't know about your
history that emerge in conversations
with other people on podcasts and things
so anyway I'm wondering what it is that
I should be asking to reveal that which
I do not yet know for our listeners and
our viewers you are a PhD in mathematics
yes your degree came from Harvard
correct your advisor was I didn't have
an advisor but wicked Wikipedia claims
that it is the person who signed my
thesis who is Raoul but Raoul about a
very famous mathematician and an
interesting good man
arguably could have maybe his
periodicity theorem could be argued to
be the theorem of the 20th century I can
make that case but he was not my advisor
highly regarded
a friend of yours but not your advisor
now I should say those who did not go to
graduate school in a science or some
some topic will probably not understand
how unusual it is to be a to have a
Doctorate without having had an advisor
in fact I don't think I've heard of
another case of that ever well in fact
they won't even let you say that that's
true even when it's true because it is
supposed to be perceived that aid an
advisor is essential to getting a PhD
which of course there's no reason that
that should be true and it isn't true
however the system expects that just the
way it can ask where did you go to
college rather than did you go to
college if you have a PhD it asks who is
your advisor and it assumes that that
has to be a condition that is met so
those who are familiar with your work
and your podcast will be well aware of
the uneasy relationship that we both
have and you have been very public about
with respect to gatekeeping the day
keeping is playing some role in our
system that many people believe is
positive in the sense that something has
to be prevented from getting through the
gate but when you actually encounter the
gatekeepers it's not what they're up to
it depends I don't think either you or I
would want to be in a world with no gate
keeping my guess is that neither of us
thinks that the gatekeeping that is
being done is of the quality to warrant
a gate yeah I mean I would say maybe my
signature issue has been captured and
that gates are one more thing where the
problem is there is a genuine version
but we haven't seen it in so long that
we only see the malignant variety and so
become those of us who have nothing but
run into these gatekeepers have the
sense of just like wipe that thing out
of the way because it's nothing but
that's right in our weaker moments I
think that the feeling is get rid of the
goddamn gatekeepers and I think that in
our stronger moments I had essentially
until 2001
never encountered a new academic subject
in which the subject was hungry for new
ideas and so when I tried to publish my
first paper in finance and the theory of
risk it was a astounding experience
because the field was hungry for new
ideas and to open up new fields so it
gave me an idea of well what must
biology or physics or economics have
been like when people were struggling to
find a paradigm rather than to defend a
bad paradigm for those who would point
out its flaws yeah my experience is that
I check in on fields that I'm capable of
evaluating which should be as many fewer
than you are but nonetheless there's a
range of biological fields for example I
can check in on them and in general I
find them asleep they're not doing
anything interesting they're sort of
spinning their wheels and then sometimes
I will check in on one after some period
away and I'll discover whoa something
has happened here and it it has caused
me to think that there's a natural
process that produces stuckness and that
that stuckness is it's not inherent to
the science it's inherent to the
sociology surrounding the way science is
done and that it's very hard to break
these things loose but sometimes
something does and we see interesting
things but how much more productive
would we be if stuckness did not
characterize most fields most of the
time well I think it's it's an
interesting question I believe that many
people reflexively quote plunk that
science proceeds funeral by funeral but
I would say it's not an addendum so much
as a pre zdenda minor you know what the
right language to cop - call it a
preamble which it would be that when a
scientific field is broken it can only
advance funeral by funeral and that is
the difference between a
well-functioning field and a poorly
functioning field whether or not it
requires the death of the licen coasst
s-- if you will who are holding back
reality wonderful now
we can talk and hopefully we'll get
later in this podcast to possible
remedies for the problem but for the
moment I think the thing that is most
pressing is for me to try to do for you
what you did for me on your podcast and
the problem is I'm not equipped to do
the job that is to say your area of I
don't want to use the word expertise
because you and I both find something
problematic about what expertise has
become but your primary area of interest
your focus is in higher math which at
some point essentially becomes
indistinguishable from or so
intermingled with physics that they are
proceeding in tandem is that fair that
they are the same subject how would you
say it so it's a it's a great question I
would say that there's an expression
that the map is not the territory and
theoretical physics in its foundational
subset that is the the discovery of what
reality is at its deepest level deepest
physical level is the one place where we
think that perhaps the map is the
territory right so in other words it's
like being handed Greenland as a map of
Greenland so I've heard you say this and
it has a how it's almost an emotional
meaning to me but I cannot make it work
analytically I can't understand what
you're trying to tell me and so I more
or less think the way to do what needs
to be done with respect to your work and
what's probably going to end up being
your greatest contribution the way to do
it is for me to reveal what I don't get
and have you try to fill me in and just
by being courageous about looking stupid
maybe we can get to a place where a lot
of people will suddenly have access to
what it is you're saying we're normally
very few well first of all I find the
dark the dark horse to be a really
interesting podcast and so to the extent
that it that you were pioneering some
new thing I'm willing to guinea pig all
right so when you say the map is the
territory I mean I was just based on our
nature I was thinking about a joke as
you were describing the math being the
territory about you know welcome to the
map or something along those lines so
what does it mean that the map is the
territory is the idea that when you so
that we tell ourselves map like stories
in every discipline all the time and
sometimes those maps are so good for our
purposes that we think we're talking
about reality but it's always models and
are you telling me that in math somehow
as we actually discover what's true you
converge on reality is that your point
we don't know whether when Albert
Einstein said let X be a four
dimensional manifold with a three one
metric and we will call it space-time we
don't know whether in some sense that
weird sentence before the word
space-time is an actual description of
what space-time is or whether or not it
is a model of what space-time is so go
ahead yeah so the the problem here is
that when Magritte for example paints
this famous painting that says Sistine
upon beep this is not a pipe he's
literally correct because it's a picture
of a pipe not a pipe mm-hmm smoking pipe
yeah well in some sense we don't know
whether Albert Einstein painted a
picture of space-time which he called a
a manifold with a 3-1 metric or 1/3
metric or whether or not he actually
described what there was at base level
and there was nothing left to find so
for example if we came to understand
that what he called space-time was made
up of tiny granular bits and that there
was a resolution and a granularity to
space-time then it wouldn't be a
continuous view beautiful expanse it
wouldn't be a continuum mm-hmm so if I
we don't know the answer to the question
about whether or not at the bottom of
theoretical physics you
is a collection of mathematical concepts
or whether they're a collection of
mathematical models and the concepts are
reality or the concepts model reality
okay now I'm gonna play the role of the
smart graduate student trying to get the
professor's attention by saying things
that are shockingly clever I don't know
if I want to pull it off let's say two
things one we have a problem with
Heisenberg's uncertainty principle which
is that we don't know if it describes
actual uncertainty or uncertainty at the
level that one measures that is not real
in other words we could have a
completely deterministic universe in
which inside of the universe we cannot
nail down all parameters simultaneously
and therefore we get the appearance of
uncertainty is this a case where we do
not know if Heisenberg has presented us
the map or the territory good good
question so in the late 1970s there was
a riff there was a revolution or maybe
the mid-1970s even that we don't talk
about called geometric quantization so
you can look up it has their books on
geometric quantization and one of the
ideas inside of geometric quantization
is that Heisenberg's uncertainty
principle originates from the fact that
a structure that we had known previously
from the 1800's called Hamiltonian
mechanics was actually a curved
geometric system where the curvature of
the system results in paradoxes because
you're sort of you had a flat earth
style expectation and then when you
encountered curvature like the triangle
with 90 degrees on every angle now
that's not supposed to happen that you
can have a triangle that's 90 90 90 but
you can on the surface of a sphere if
you bent a triangle around a sphere or
if you call it a curved linear triangle
on a sphere and you're talking about
spherical geometry it's a legitimate
triangle not just a bent one so in other
words implicitly your intuition pump had
come from flat space you didn't make an
adaptation when it became part of a
curved system and the curvature gave you
the idea that something impossible was
happening which is that you could have
three angles all
of them 90 degrees well it turns out
that you it may be that the degree of
failure to the to the ability which you
can measure these two quantities
position and momentum simultaneously may
be due to curvature and it's the
curvature of something called a line
bundle inside of something called
geometric quantization coming from
Hamiltonian mechanics which was one of
the two main schools of how to do a
physics problem so you start off with
something that's fairly ancient that you
could either do Hamiltonian or
Lagrangian physics two different ways of
coming up with an answer if the system
starts like this how will it develop and
there was a hidden feature it was like
an easter egg that hadn't been found and
really until let's say that around the
1970s and that easter egg says hey you
know this upcoming thing that you're
gonna find in in quantum mechanics which
is Heisenberg's uncertainty principle
turns out that that's actually coming
back from a an easter egg that was
partially unearthed by William Hamilton
there's a William there's somebody
Hamilton that's my Hamilton okay
the Hamilton mammoth math Hamilton of
quaternion have forgotten what his name
is okay I was feeling smart and then I
started feeling stupid again hey I have
a feeling no that's this is this is par
for the course um I have a feeling that
when you say curvature that I don't know
what you mean because I'm very tempted
to take it more literally than I should
and that it's almost like literal
literal curvature but that there's a way
in which it's more metaphorical than
that but let me ask you just to check on
whether I got what you said at all sure
if Heisenberg's uncertainty is the
result of curvature rather than actual
uncertainty in linear space mm-hmm on 3d
space then you could have a
deterministic universe in which the
appearance of uncertainty would be there
but it would not actually be uncertain
as a result of the fact that it is
coming from curvature well so that's not
even where the uncertainty comes from
really it should be Kaizen bergs non
commutativity relationship rather than
as an uncertainty principle so in part
the Linguistics have gotten us very
fouled up so I've made the case on a
recent essay on my own podcast the
portal which I begin each episode now
with an audio essay by the way those
audio essays are fantastic really I
don't know if I've heard every one of
them I think I might have to really
appreciate every one I've heard spot on
brain isn't brilliantly written I really
appreciate that thank you makes me
wonder what you're setting me up for
later ah you'll see okay what what I
would say is is that in this recent
essay I had to make the point which is
very tough on people that classical
mechanics is deterministic in one sector
and that sector when it becomes quantum
mechanics is exactly as deterministic as
classical mechanics like all of the
uncertainty in quantum theory of quantum
measurement occurs in a second sector
where classical mechanics doesn't know
how to answer a problem and so it
remains mute and you can't say it's
deterministic or non-deterministic so
for example you know if I asked you
whether you're wearing are you either a
wearing a bandanna or be wearing a
jacket that's a tough question in
classical mechanics you'd say not a good
question yeah in quantum mechanics we'd
say well 50% of the time you'll be
wearing a bandanna and the jacket will
disappear and 50% of the time you'll be
wearing a jacket and the bandanna will
disappear well with respect to this
question I feel like I'm in a
superposition but I'm not enjoying
you're in one of the best positions made
wonderful okay yeah so that that
weirdness
nobody remarks upon which is that it was
in the sector where we're asking what
I've called bad questions that is every
question come in quantum theory comes
with an implicit multiple choice list if
the answer is not on the multiple choice
list quantum mechanics just guesses and
a guess is according to some formula as
to how likely it is to make every guess
if it is on the list it always guesses
correctly
it's completely deterministic and so by
reef casting so I'm trying to get rid of
the linguistic associations you're
coming in with Heisenberg you know
something there's a cat
something about a double snip you
haven't even figured out why you're
pissing me off yet okay here's the thing
I get the quantum weirdness thing I've
stared at it I get that fully embracing
the fact that what I'm understanding
can't possibly be right and yet it is
that part it's not that I know what to
make of it but I know how to accept it
what I don't accept is that there's any
ambiguity between deterministic universe
and not deterministic universe and so I
guess my question is are you telling me
that there is some wiggle between those
two because I feel like it's completely
discrete that either there is some
wiggle right there's some uncertainty
that comes somewhere and everything that
appears to us to be somewhat uncertain
is somehow bootstrapped up from that
thing or it ain't and we are permanently
billiard balls bouncing in a totally
predictable way around a billiard table
and this is just some absurd obnoxious
spectacle of the illusion of chance Wow
well the part of the problem is is that
you probably have an Einsteinian picture
well no and a quantum mechanical in it
like a but I think God does play dice I
think he has to where evolution wouldn't
work as you know I know you don't
believe that argument but I believe that
you have an intuition pump that it
effectively says that the peculiarities
of an aardvark or something are so
bizarre to imagine that it's encoded
into the initial state of the universe
is beyond preposterous
now Stephen Wolfram is coming out with
an idea that certain simple rules give
birth to fabulous levels of complexity
as we saw with like the Mandelbrot set
so that that's an entire blind alley to
go down which people like there's
certain oh I don't want to go down the
blind well I'm just telling you I'm not
I'm not asking you to explain to me why
we're on one side of this puzzle the
other side of this puzzle or it's an
unresolvable puzzle cause it doesn't
mean anything what I want to know is do
you actually know the answer to the
question let's put it this way there's a
question about what would
be true if my most optimistic and
aggressive version of my theory were
true cool I'm gonna correct you yeah
they're gonna hate this okay hey why why
am I doing this then there's the thing
you say theory yeah and I believe you
are borrowing something now that is
going to rob you incredibly in the
future and so I hate it but it's a it's
a if it's physics it's a hypothesis if
it's math I guess it's a postulate but
it can't be a theory yet okay I don't
want to get into that whatever that cool
well we'll come back to it you're just
putting a placeholder to escape a
difficulty that I can't yet see in 12
dimension no no no no no all right what
I want is when it becomes a theory
because it is actually established
something in the real world I want it to
pull away from all of the other crap
okay okay and the word theory is the way
that works in some fields and not in
others for some reason I don't know
where you're headed but I'm happy to
have you our happiness nary theory is a
theory because we have established that
it is true to some high degree through
experiments and observations I don't
want to get into this dream theory isn't
a theory I would agree that string
theory isn't a theory but I I'm specific
enough about what this thing is okay I
don't I don't fear the word we will just
put an asterisk just usually about this
that's fine what I was gonna say is is
that I don't buy into what you probably
believe about the world which is I don't
think that right now you and I are in
three dimensions having a progressing
conversation in a forth called time yeah
so as a result of that one of the issues
is that you have to go beyond Einstein
if you're going to resolve certain
resolve if you're going to attempt to
resolve any problems generated by
Einstein like black holes why are their
singular solutions or the initial
singularity which we sort of mapped to
the timer and the Big Bang or something
like that those problems in my mind and
some others that I think are more
significant and somehow people don't
care about which I find bizarre indicate
that there's something beyond Einstein
and if there is something beyond
Einstein you have to ask all the
questions that I formulated inside of
his world yeah do I know what their
analog is in the larger structure so my
guess is whenever I see the amount of
ink spilled over something like quantum
theory and indeterminacy and uncertainty
and all those sorts of things
entanglement many worlds I immediately
say Oh
sounds like people are in the wrong
paradigm trying to ask questions
prematurely about what would be relevant
in the next paradigm
it's flatland you got Flatlanders you
got floating around trying to figure out
higher dimensions would be one problem
and curvature which would be another
problem they can't figure out either of
these two and so the only reason for
engaging in that stuff is usually to
break the paradigm or its recreation
it's like you're not really serious so
might as well have a half-hour
discussion about freewill
ain't no interest it I've been in those
discussions they're not fun but before
we laid them before we leave Einstein I
want to make my other point and see
whether it lands or doesn't land with
you so you say so let's first say
sitting in three dimensions with time as
a fourth dimension does not describe the
four dimensional manifold a four
dimensional manifold my understanding
would be that that's actually a four
dimensional shape and so a creature that
lives in this four dimensional shape but
experiences one of the dimensions
differently
the quirk is with the creature right the
shape is four dimensional and the
creature is you know has an accounting
secesh I mean I would say that the
weirdness is that if you think about it
as Gladys Knight and her three pips
where time is Gladys and the pips are
spatial dimensions called XY and Z let's
say that world is one in which time is
somewhat broken out as special yeah and
somewhat not like you can trade off
small amounts of time for some small
amount of space but you can't treat time
wholesale as space okay
so there's a weird way in which time is
distinguished there's a weird way in
which time is one of the one of the
Bands okay so this actually brings me to
the point so first of all you and I are
in some ways quite similar cognitively
and in some ways we are opposites right
I I believe that because you existed in
the world I was born into I ended up
moving in the direction of complexity
that is biology and away from the
ultimate fundamentals and you often when
I say something like this you correct me
and you say yes you treat biology like a
fundamental though which is true if that
is that is what I did with it but the
way I did that was but there a couple
things that are true of biology that
make it dead simple compared to stuff
that you're working on one of them is at
the end of the day creatures have to
make sense
right they don't have to make sense to
you but they have to make sense in some
meaningful way and so it's a simpler
puzzle right
we don't have quantum weirdness in
biology because the creatures have to
eat and they have to you know bring in
enough energy and all that the other
thing is biology is much more tolerant
of a kind of logical cheating you can
get you can get used to where sloppiness
is allowed and where it isn't and you
can take advantage of the the tolerances
that come from the places where
sloppiness doesn't really hurt you one
of the places that I've found that you
can be very sloppy in biology and make a
ton of profit is with the following
claim and anytime you see a pattern in
space there's another pattern in time
that looks just like it and it probably
goes by some other name and nobody's
noticed the relationship so you can kind
of double your returns just by taking
everything you think you know in either
time or space and looking for the analog
and the other paradigm so a version of
this outside of that would be that I'd
take thinking we seem to say lots of
things about the word thinking
overthinking groupthink critical
thinking we never say it about feeling
so if I just replace everywhere I see
the word thinking I talk about you're
over feeling this you're experiencing
group feel we have to try to feel from
first principles
all that kind of stuff people are
shocked because you come up with these
brilliant concepts and they really are
brilliant but you have a formula that
actually generates brilliant and to be
honest in economics PN I my wife
exploited the fact that you we know that
you can't integrate people across space
so that voting has its own problems and
we know this is the arrow impossibility
theorem from something called social
choice theory and it turns out that what
is impossible in space is possible
across time because time has an extra
piece of information which is let's say
we took you me Heather and Pia before of
us in space if you could morph me into
you and you and to Pia and Pia into
Heather you'd have a continuous variable
that connects us that's something that
you have with one agent over time many
instance of time rather than one instant
of time and having many agents so
sometimes there's a false duality to
this sometimes there's a true duality
and yes this is an absolutely
interesting issue where people don't
notice that there is that which works
across these reflections and changes a
variable and dualities and that which
does not okay I completely lost what you
were getting at when you had us
transmuting into each other I didn't get
that for you want to compare your tastes
and what whether you're better off in a
future instant of time given that you've
changed your tastes over time yeah turns
out that we have a way of doing that
where the field thought that was
impossible if we want to compare a bunch
of people's different tastes you could
do that if you had a morphing of me into
you you into somebody else somebody else
into somebody else I see and therefore
the idea is is that with an extra piece
of data there would be a duality between
time and space but even the great Ken
arrow arguably the greatest of
mathematical economists of modern times
was fooled into thinking you Eric cannot
possibly be telling me that you guys
have solved the problem of intertemporal
tastes because that would imply a
solution to inter agent taste comparison
and I proved that that was impossible
therefore we
you do as impossible then I had to say
to him nope
youuuu blown it you didn't understand
that there was an extra piece of data
which made time different than space so
am i right that this is a kludge the
thing about occlude for those of you who
are not familiar with the term Cluj is a
basically an engineering term where a
kludge is an elegant but highly
functional solution what's what is a
kludge in this case in this case the
fact that you can use that obviously
there's nobody transmuting into anybody
else but if you treat somebody as
transmuting into somebody else you can
apparently solve a problem that you
would be able but then the solution
would depend on the transmutation and
since that's not real if you can't
remove that dependence on that extra
piece of structure that you've now
invoked you know so yes the idea is that
I can solve the arrow impossibility
theorem with an extra piece of data
which is a continuum that connects all
members of the society together does
that ever work out to be meaningful I've
never seen a meaningful example of it
okay so I think I am trying to riff and
play with you know yeah I think it's
good for one thing for one thing I think
maybe the most important thing you know
I don't know exactly who's in your
audience but I would imagine that just
simply discovering that with something
you know two people who've spent a
lifetime exchanging information to speak
each other's language and all that when
you're talking about a gap this big yeah
there's a lot of like spinning your
wheels and you scratching your head and
not knowing what's going on and that it
does result in progress but you know
being sort of empowered to say no I
don't get that yet yeah probably for
okay people who care about her what
you're talking about it's probably
useful okay so if I get you so far
yeah there's most people have a problem
at the gap between three and four
dimensions they're uneasy with what it
means that time is a dimension in some
sense analogous to the first three I'm
there I do that one pretty easily maybe
I've got some sloppiness in my thinking
about it but you're telling me that what
I don't get is that that
we're dimensional universe that I'm kind
of you know I've taken off the training
wheels but I'm no expert in yeah that
that thing is actually the training
wheel land for a larger universe that I
know from past things you said is
fourteen dimension yeah okay and so then
I agree when you say you know it's
fourteen dimensional I can say okay well
there's you know there's 14 bits or
something right it's fourteen bit color
or I don't know what I so I can sort of
understand what it would mean to have a
fourteen dimensional space but I don't
understand how you would know if you're
in one and what its implications might
be well people get very hung up because
they don't understand that not all
dimensions or visual dimensions or
spatial dimensions so for example very
few people get upset when they buy a
piece of audio equipment and it says
treble mid-range bass volume reverb okay
well that's five dimensions to me yeah
and then they're like well that's not a
real dimension they're thinking and I'm
saying okay well then I and now I know
what your confusion is is that you've
been told that dimensions are spatial or
visual spatial dimensions and so you're
gonna reject every number the distant
three yep okay so I'm gonna say well it
seems to me like when you eat when you
order food you're thinking about sweet
salty bitter sour pain for you know
those chili peppers and heat that's so
there's six dimensions going on your
tongue before I even get started and
you're not freaked out that you've got
six dimensions worth of taste and the
only problem is is that you're trying to
cram those into your visual court well
how can I see them well you don't see
those tastes either you taste them so
you know your your mouth is at least six
dimensional based on what we just said
now it's very important that you
understand that you're not dealing with
super minds or like just a second breath
I'm going to see the 14th dimension no
you can't do it because you're a mere
mortal but I your older brother I've
seen farther than other men yes all
right
so okay you are solving a problem here
for me so terrific when you say so I
think I'm being misled
by my experience which is the first
three dimensions are similar to each
other the fourth dimension is unique
feeling but parallel in some sense to
the spatial dimensions or maybe the one
dimension of time is parallel to the
three dimensions of space or something
like that and so I have the sense of
like oh this isn't getting easier as we
add dimensions this is getting weirder
and more complex and what you're telling
me is that it may be that some of the
stuff that's above the level that I can
conceptualize it our simple bit flips or
something that doesn't you know add
indefinitely large amounts of complexity
but you need to be aware of them or else
everything everything but we could do
the whole thing visually so for example
for those of those people who are
watching this rather than listening to
this I'm now holding my glass of
recently drained kombucha and the rim of
it seems to be close to a circle now if
space were just one space time or just
one circular dimension yeah then I would
claim that the enlarged structure so in
my theory four becomes 14 the one
dimension that is the one parameter
people will think a circle is two
dimension again it lives in two
dimension yeah but because there's only
one to give me you know only need one
number to say where you are on the
circle just give me the angle yeah right
that circle would generate something of
the one original dimension plus one
dimension which for me would be a way to
measure length at every point on the
circle so a different ruler to measure
length so we don't get this yet there
are an infinite number of points around
that circle tonight the circle is
infinitely divisible you're saying you
want a different ruler for each so as
finely as I divide you want a different
ruler for each point I want a rule that
tells me how to measure length on the
line tangent to that circle at any given
point ok so EV of a there an infinite
number of tangents to the circle if you
want to measure how much of a line
segment you have you want a ruler that
allows I wanted
line at every point okay tangent to that
circle yeah and then I want a different
ruler a rule that tells me how I can
measure distance along that line where
it doesn't have to all come from one
ruler that I place at every point why
that's the thing is throwing seems like
one ruler that you can just tell it
where to measure is good enough why
would you want a special one for each
tangent well because you're borrowing
the fact that that this glass is living
in three dimensional space okay and
because of that and because three
dimensional space seems to have one
ruler right like you don't buy a
different ruler for your ex to rent
dimensions your Y your Z so the idea is
you go off to Amazon or the local
hardware store you buy a ruler and that
ruler is living in three-dimensional
space now I give you a problem you know
like I'll Cal go I'll just go get my one
great ruler yeah and I'm gonna measure
at every point
well this circle in my story is the
analog of space-time before it gets to
become space-time so call it proto
spacetime because what Einstein did
effectively let's just make it weird he
said take the four dimensions of taste
on your tongue sweet salty sour and
bitter come up with a different
intensity scale for each of those things
call that a ruler and then come up with
angles between them ah what how do I
know whether sweet is very similar to
sour because sweet and sour go well
together or is it really that it's kind
of opposite so is it some kind of Delta
between the experiences right how
different is sweetness we don't know so
I'm trying to invent a world which isn't
the three-dimensional world in which you
and I seem to be you're trying to find
an analog world and of course I'm trying
to build you an intuition pump so the
idea is that your visual cortex in the
back of your head since we're doing
biology yeah is a huge hindrance to you
yeah and that huge hindrance is that
you're gonna map everything back to that
and since everything came with rulers
and protractors and you're not going to
be able to think about a world before
rulers and protractors and since
Einstein's principle insight with
Grossman I might add this is before
Einstein breaks out into GR as most
physicists now think about it
was to say I bet that the geometry that
we call differential geometry or romani
and geometry or semi remaining or pseudo
Roman whatever this kind of geometry was
that came up in Germany way back when
this geometry is the right way to model
our universe but your universe contains
the geometric assumptions already so
you're sort of saying like I don't
understand what did he do doesn't seem
like much so I'm trying to say okay
let's talk about your tongue we know for
example that there's like a Scoville
scale for pain for peppers mm-hmm okay
that's weird it's a ruler that's a ruler
to tell you how how intense
okay my guess is the people who make
artificial sweetners probably have a
sweetness scale yeah and we don't know
how the sweetness scale and the pain
scale interact like are those the same
ruler was there any thought of the
intensity to make sure that it's common
between the resep receptors like you
know what is their threshold to get your
attention maybe the idea is below a
certain threshold you don't it doesn't
get your attention it yeah you call that
one now you've normalized your rulers
across all of the different tastes my
point in this is when it comes to pure
taste forget pain and forget heat for
the moment yeah you've got four major
kinds of receptor that we know about
those four receptors are like proto
space-time it's like Einstein before he
puts the metric which is the rulers and
protractors on the thing that we call
space-time you and I are inheriting
rulers and protractors from Einstein
spacetime okay so I I get the intuition
pump problem okay
I get the the analogy that's throwing me
but I can correct for it with the tongue
because obviously that's an evolutionary
space and how intense the pain is has
everything it's just four degrees of
freedom that didn't come equipped with
the thing that you're always gonna say
like I don't understand
we have rollers and protractors just go
out and get one and measure stuff yeah
the idea is okay well on your tongue you
don't have that so when you say rulers
and protractors yep this is I'm I don't
know if this is right but I'm asking you
you are saying there are two different
kinds of Delta where you want to measure
the difference between two things
sometimes you're talking about something
and
to a length than your ruler sometimes
you're talking about something that's
you know an angle difference you want a
protractor okay what I don't get is what
length and angle are analogized to I
know how Lane I know how lanes and
angles work but I don't know well we
would say in in in grownup math land is
Oh at every point you need a metric
which is a symmetric non-degenerate two
tensor that's a bunch of language but
I've read it again slower there is a
gadget which is effectively a
combination ruler and protractor and you
have to extract length style and angle
style information from it but it's
basically in four dimensions a four by
four matrix so 16 entries in which if
you flip across the diagonal going from
the Northwest to the southeast it has to
be symmetric under a flip so once you've
got the top triangle of that diagram
concentrated in the northeast corner and
you flip that into the southwest all the
information is reflected from that
object I can get length and angle
information so what when I whenever I
talk to lay audiences I don't talk about
symmetric non-degenerate to tensors you
do more than you think but much less
than my colleagues I talk about oh it's
just rulers and protractors and over and
over again you'll hear me talk about
rulers and protractors so what I'm
really talking about to a math audience
is a four by four matrix at every point
in essence symmetric about its diagonal
but the content of that is at least as
far as Einstein was pushing and I'm
pushing it farther just ruler and
protractor information and from that it
turns out that curvature is in emergent
quantity which is kind of a giant shock
we all sort of think we know what we
mean by saying something is curved
mathematicians figured out oh it turns
out you can recover curvature as a
consequence of just having rulers and
protractors with just a highly
non-trivial observation yeah I mean it
strikes me as hinted at by the mechanism
that both
the Greeks and the Chinese used to
figure out pi to sort of narrow in on pi
right that basically what you're using
is non curved math to approximate what
happens as you get to curvature well we
have a series of things that we do like
the idea of a tangent vector when we
have the rim of my glass and I talked
about the line tangent to the glass you
could say well if you don't put your
glass inside of a three-dimensional
world how do you know about the line
tangent and mathematicians say ah we
don't actually need to put the glass and
its rim inside of a larger space we used
to but now we learned how to talk about
tangent see from the point of view of
differential operators in Newton's
calculus it's like okay so the analog
the sorry the the concept that you
learned about in high school is
something having magnitude and direction
yeah turns out to be a differential
operator yep laughs I was just gonna ask
you about this yes is the reason that we
are talking about rulers and protractors
because of their relationship to a
vector well it's it is vectors that we
are measuring to say what their length
is and what their angle is yeah
even the word length is a lie because
there are nonzero vectors that everyone
would agree that it's nonzero that would
have nonzero length and then people said
wait a minute you just blow my mind that
Y is non zero length trebling sorry they
would have zero length zero line so you
have non zero vectors which have zero
length because we took a word that you
know very well and then we borrowed it
someplace where you really don't have
any intuition at all and now I just you
know it's like blowing somebody's mind
at a Christmas party wait there are
vectors that are not zero but they have
zero length Wow tell me more well it's a
hundred percent having to do with the
linguistic encoding of the word length
it does not have to do I mean there's
obviously a tremendous amount of
weirdness that happens at zero which I'm
not claiming that I'm not claiming it's
not weird but it's not as weird as
saying that in
zero object has zero length that's like
what physicists and math people do to
blow people's minds and get them
interested in the subject and then we
unblown your mind later by teaching you
what we really meant so it's kind of a
not my favorite way of getting people in
the door of math and physics so I don't
know I don't know if we're just goofing
off here but you know I used to say I'm
not a good dancer but I did spend a
little time when I was in Latin America
we're good dancer
around the time of your wedding that's
okay but what I learned I mean I was
always mortified by dancing and what I
learned that kind of you know was one of
the few things that broke it loose from
me was that it was very important that
you do something on every beat even if
what you do is nothing right does Beth
the formulation sort of allowed me to
think through it rather than you know
hopping all over these beats and not
knowing when you were supposed to do
what so anyway it sort of sounds like
the same sort of thing that you've got
some sort of nonzero object that has
zero length you've got something that
agrees with the concept of length in the
realm that you're familiar with it that
extends into a realm that you've never
thought much about so if you extend the
word length you blow your own mind but
if you were to say like something about
the weight of a vector and I could say
well this vector has weight zero but it
is not zero itself right yeah so that
then the idea and use weight there
because they're fully because you can
get zero weight without having zero mass
and so the first time you realize this
okay so it's some level if I if I if I
call it length which is to extend the
word that you already knew yeah then
you'll have the wrong intuition so what
I did was I cleverly sort of misdirected
you as a magician into wrong intuition
and that caused your mind to explode and
that then I get to go home saying well
I'm smarter than he is and I hate that
game yeah I don't like that game either
and you know I'm also I like the game of
where's my intuition misleading me
yep that's a you know so this also this
is partially when I'm not trying when
I'm not pretending as an impostor to do
physics research I'm pretending as an
impostor
to be a pedagogue and to clear up
people's confusions that are left by
other physicists or mathematicians who
are intentionally trying to blow
people's minds okay
yeah no that's a that's because I'd
rather blow your mind in an honest way
that causes you to want to stay engaged
rather than just say wow the universe
can fit inside of my fingernails
you would rather blow our minds
consequentially rather than by virtue of
the fact that something sounds amazing
yeah yeah okay good
so all right there's some sort of 14
dimensional space you've let me just say
a little word about that okay imagine
that your proto space-time was like an
infinitely thin hair band okay
hair band like Aerosmith or I would have
gone with poison but anyway all right
I think Aerosmith is more timeless but
let's keep on least everybody's heard
all right so I would say that if you
started off with an infinitely thin hair
band then for every point on that hair
band imagine this space of all possible
things that you went call of unit length
all possible rulers okay and allow that
a ruler can be either marked with
positive numbers or negative numbers for
whatever reason yeah but you're not
allowed to choose the zero ruler
there's no way in which you can claim
that everything is of zero length or
infinite length I don't understand what
a zero ruler would be let's not worry
too much about it okay what I would
claim is that the object that I would
create if I did the same thing which I'm
doing to four dimensions turning it into
14 would turn the hairband into two
toilet paper cores the cardboard cores
would be two disconnected cylinders and
you can see that the circular nature of
the hairband would be represented in the
circular nature okay so I get so you get
it you take AB and let's imagine that
this was done on the computer screen
right you've got a circle right this is
a hairband of no dimension right and you
stretch it across something that gives
you a tube well what I would say is is
that
along that tube is every possible going
lengthwise down the tube is every
possible ruler with the same sign so the
reason you have to high is because
there's a positive in a negative there's
a positive in the negative that's why
you have to do so effectively you took a
long tube you cut a middle part of the
tube out because those that would be the
degenerate metrics so as this you can't
have one tube that goes from positive
through negative because of a divided by
0 problem you can't have that because
then you would say that there are
directions which can't be measured as
having a nonzero weight if you will or
length or whatever you want to call it
relative to every possible thing so
every possible measurement could yield
zero if you choose a degenerate
symmetric - tensor so remember some
things can only serve as rulers and
protractors if they aren't pathological
so all we're doing is getting rid of the
stuff that is pathological and saying
I'm sorry that there was a little bit of
fly in your soup sir we've removed all
the Flies from you I still want to know
when you say pathological zero is
weirdly pathological you know there you
can't divide by zero or you'll blow your
computer up right so there's a problem
with zero that doesn't tell you anything
about immediately adjacent so you don't
know of any way of handling the case
where the rulers and protractors are
effectively going to return zero for
certain directions in all circles so
you're better off just saying look we
can deal with this toilet paper tube and
we can deal with that that toilet paper
tube and they know it connect but that's
okay because yeah okay got it so now if
we if we took the hair band and then we
said you know what let's let's up our
game a little bit because the hairband
you can't there's no space it's either
all space or all time depending upon
whether you chose the plus rulers or the
minus rule is if you chose the minus
rulers it's all time if you chose the
plus rulers it's all space okay wait
you're blowing my mind stop it
why would the sign is that arbitrary
that sort of okay so in other words it
doesn't tell you that space should be
plus and that time should be minus and
because you I need some way of
distinguishing some time from some space
and if you want to do everything
backwards from my conventions feel free
to call space negative and time positive
got it I believe that the we east coast
in the west coast of the US chose
different conventions in terms of the
university oh really I think there's an
East Room and there's a physics thing
mathematicians almost never we know
about this stuff
but it's not our lifeblood in general we
prefer everything to be all pust all
plus or all negative right we would call
that Romani in geometry we know about
semi Romani and geometry is just not
very important to us it happens with the
one case of geometry that's really
important in the outside world it's
mixed because it's one time and three
space so are you telling me that
mathematicians are forced into a
landscape of half plus and half minus
and when you want to talk about general
relativity and we want to talk about
physics we know that the case that we
don't like which is mixed signature yeah
is the one that is physically relevant
so it's sort of perverse that we would
prefer to be in what would be called
Euclidean signature that is all plus or
all - yeah and that's where we do our
geometry but our physicist friends the
one case that they really like is this
mixed signature case ok so is it that
they are bringing this stuff to the
table that forces you into their zone we
came up with an abstraction yeah
they applied it in one case so our
imagine you're a software company yeah
and you didn't correctly anticipate who
would want to run your software so
you've got one amazing government
contract let's imagine yeah and it's for
a use that you never imagined would be
your leading use case like somebody's
got a weird use of your product and
that's your only client so your only
client outside of your pure shop that's
keeping you afloat is in the one case
that your engineers don't like working
on that
but if we could just suspend the
physicists yeah and you could translate
this all into plus or minus it's not
that the universe we'd still do it but
it would be done in some obscure
department very often what happens is is
that if you have a special case somebody
who's not at the center of the world and
it doesn't have the ability to kind of
constantly check in with what happened
this week yeah we'll take it over so
like you'll have a Uruguay community
that cares about some special thing and
it's great at some level because it
means that somebody makes some important
case their life's work it's like if
you're the guy who's in charge of the
platypus you have to really know your
stuff on that one system but that system
is so different than everything else
that maybe you know you're not the
generalist ya know it removes the
cognitive burden from those who have to
juggle a bunch of things which would
otherwise be and there's some dialogue
because you know quite honestly the
platypus is more important than just as
an exception because it actually had a
huge thing to say about mammalian
evolution so in this case I would say it
turns out that the physics community
keeps us interested in a class of
equations called hyperbolic equations
that are really important that maybe we
would discount and we'd stay in the case
of what we'd call elliptic equations so
this happens I don't know why it comes
to mind but in biology this happens
around mites so mites are of course
everywhere crawling all over everything
but they're in general very tiny and so
most of us biologists just don't even
pay attention to the fact that they're
there but the mite people are really
interesting and they have this kind of
bent in fact Heather and I had a friend
George Hammond who used to say you know
there'd be some seminar on some plant
dynamics he'd say it's always a mite
angle so anyway yeah mites are the zone
of special people who you know enter the
conversation when something turns out to
determine to be dependent on this so I
was gonna say well though is is that if
you if you up the game and you say okay
now I want to play with two dimensions
so I have one time to
in one space dimension at least that
starts to sound like reality because
space and time are different yeah so
then you'd be in a two dimensional world
and you'd have one ruler in the time
dimension one ruler and the in the space
dimension so think about a watch versus
an actual ruler and you'd have an angle
between the two which would be your
protractor so there'd be three pieces of
extra data and then if you threw out
just the way you cut through that like
let's say paper towel core have your
positive and your negative now you've
got three pieces of that
three-dimensional space of two rulers
plus one protractor and it looks like a
giant butterfly and it takes
three-dimensional space and it cuts out
it looks you know that thing jugglers
use called a Diablo which is like oh
they're like they are it's a wheel on a
string oh yeah right
it's sort of that the bad stuff now
looks like kind of the beginning of a
Diablo and so you have three sections
two in the wings call it a butterfly ER
and then there's one that kind of goes
around where the string would normally
go on that kind of flywheel contraption
and those three things would be the
three different possible signatures to
to to of time none of space one of time
in one of space two of space
none of time so those are the three
possible ways of dividing up two
dimensions into three into space and
time okay this is this is one of many
points along the way where I begin to
doubt that I know what we are even
discussing well all I'm trying to get at
is people want to know what's new what
are you doing and they don't usually go
back to well what is we already
established is pretty solid and
interesting so Einstein told us that
space-time is four dimensions four
possible degrees of freedom with rulers
and protractors and the ruler that goes
in the direction of the time is of a
different nature than the rulers that go
in the direction of space
and there are six angles rather than in
this case that we just did one angle
because there was only one time in one
space and that is where we begin the
puzzle which is how does one
disintermediate Einstein like if
Einstein has a flaw and Einsteins flaw
is holding us back and by the way this
is a terrifying thing to say because we
all love Einstein sure which we don't
get we don't want to get rid of the guy
yeah we can't disentangle the lovable
guy who made huge progress from the
possibility that we're his work well you
have to trust that you're gonna that
what you do will honor him in the end
but you can't honor him in the middle
you actually have to go after him in the
middle yeah is the tough part right and
and in some sense he was just such a
beautiful soul that we also want to make
sure that we don't do any damage to that
soul yeah okay so in this situation what
I would say is Einstein threw away all
but the space-time metric that he
believed in so in other words he didn't
allow the stuff in the universe to dance
on top of the rulers and protractors he
just chose one set of rulers and
protractors and then he said that the
stuff in the universe is engaged in one
equation called the Einstein field
equations with that stuff okay so I know
I'm full of [ __ ] here but I also have a
feeling it's metaphorically right okay
this is the thing that's that causes
fields to get stuck and it is that
diminishing returns causes a cognitive
failure and the cognitive failure is
that that which works really well
becomes reinforced as the mechanism to
go forward because at a temporary moment
which may be an entire career you're
going forward with this thing and so you
become convinced that it's very very
accurate and the problem is it's
accurate until it starts robbing you
good so what I would say is you are
making an appeal towards a paradigm that
we most often associate with economics
even though it shouldn't be associated
with the economics right what I would
then say is in fact the parallel is
better with
evolutionary theory which is your old
stomping ground of civil right and
adaptive landscape theory the key point
is you have to go down in a valley to
get to a higher peak you may be on the
highest point of the peak that you know
about on a local optimum and that's
where we got stuck which is everything
you do that you try to go beyond
Einstein if you get punished yeah yeah
yeah no this is exactly right and it
arms those who want to stick to the
paradigm which then becomes an economic
problem because we award the power in
these fields to those who have made
great progress and then they're in a
position at the point that they well
then we get in a different situation
which I don't I mean if you really want
to expand on that I would say they
become the Catholic Church and they
start to hand out indulgences which is
if you want to violate the paradigm this
particular violation of the paradigm is
blessed and all others are cursed Yeah
right and so the idea is we're going to
suspend the usual rules about experiment
let's say for string theorists we're so
brilliant that they don't need to be in
touch with experiment but everyone else
who comes up with an idea we're gonna
immediately ask what does it predict so
dude yeah this is why I want you to
consider the possibility that theory is
the wrong designation because if so
here's the point over in biology space
we swear that evolution when we say it's
just a theory we don't mean anything
less it's as close to saying its effect
as we ever get right it has been so
thoroughly demonstrated to be accurate
that we are treating it as a fact until
we discover something that dislodges it
like this is all a simulation and
evolution was put in it to see what we
would think right something like that so
evolution is as close to effect as we
get and we call it a theory my point
would be at the point that your work
predicts things in the world that lead
us to understand that it is at least
highly accurate and maybe
the final step in our quest to figure
out how the universe works
then it becomes a theory and there's
only ever one theory at a time right but
the problem is over in physics because
physics people are sloppy about this
language
you've got people string theorists
engaged in string theory and the thing
is their work doesn't even rise to the
level of hypothesis I'll say things like
it's not a theory it's a program but
that's my point
it's actually yeah Phylis philosophy of
science wise string theory is an
interpretation kit I want to try to say
something a little bit more horrible
okay why are we spending our time in
philosophy of science when we as science
scientists spend too much time in
philosophy of science we have failed and
one of my concerns is is that with all
of the ink spilled on what is science
what is a science what is a theory what
is a hope what is a prediction that's
what happens when people aren't able to
do good science for a long period of
time no no I believe you are making a
mistake and by the way you make an
excellent point about what you call
desperation physics so I believe you are
conflating think that may have been
Powell Eastern well you and Hallie have
done very well with this art but in any
case desperation physics is real I'm
well familiar with it philosophy can
become another version of desperation
physics or desperation whatever science
you want to talk about it is not
inherently that and so my point would be
you actually don't need to spend a lot
of time in philosophy of science space
but you need to spend enough time and
that in effect what you've got in
physics is you have the string the so
called string theory community which is
effectively like all of the suitors and
other lowlifes in the in the in the
manor right and Odysseus is coming home
to liberate the manor and save Penelope
right the point is the the coming home
the stringing the bow the saving
Penelope
is actually done with the philosophy
that says these people are not
legitimate here how do we know because
they have dressed up a notion that maybe
if we're generous is an interpretation
they have dressed it up as if it has the
power of a theory it doesn't even want
rise to the level of hypothesis but
they're claiming it's a theory
these people are illegitimate and so
anyway I think that the amount I mean
you know that took three sentences four
sentences and the amount of power that
comes from recognizing why are we taking
this as seriously as a hypothesis or a
theory when it doesn't rise to that
level so let me just sort of say this
somebody set up a 24/7 chat room
facility on the discord platform for the
portal community and when I pop in by
you know some some means by which I'm
quiet and I listen to what people are
talking about a huge amount of the time
they're talking about is their free will
are there many worlds is something a
scientific hypothesis what I'm actually
interested in is to tell them these are
very expensive conversations that are
gonna take a tremendous amount of your
life because you're going to assume that
there's more to this and quite honestly
you and I can be in different places my
feeling about this is science is the
totality of things that have worked to
produce fairly reliable knowledge and at
the end of the day I believe that this
is about taste and about not wanting to
be thwacked you know in general most
musicians have a pretty clear idea about
the hierarchy of musicianship music is a
very large space it's not linearly
ordered I'm not going to pretend that we
all you know have the same favorite
guitarists but most of the time you can
say you know Hilary Hahn is one of the
greatest violinists in the world and
everybody knows it and when science is
working we don't spend a lot of time
saying is this science we spent a lot of
time talking about is the science is
this settled when we're in politics
space when the feel
stagnated when there's a dispute in
which people refuse to say that logic or
data adjudicated and this may be
different for evolutionary theory in
physics but from my perspective I don't
enjoy being dragged into the demarcation
problem by people who want to say oh
you're a consequentialist or I actually
I'm coming here compatible I I'm from an
EOP Parian perspective it's like oh is
that are you telling me that you don't
do work yeah I don't I don't think I'm
telling you what you think I'm telling
you okay
because the other part of this riff is
that this is not supposed to be
scientists having this discussion yeah
but the scientists and like we've been
so dead for so long in what I care about
it's it's all dead I mean you've got an
entire Academy for wintered evolutionary
theory stuff 1976 pretty much not
entirely but pretty much yeah and pretty
much in some sense the kind of
theoretical physics that I weep over and
gives me jitters stopped around 1973
okay now my point would be somehow we
civilization subsidizes a certain number
of philosophers including a certain
number of philosophers of science who
are confused
for the most part into thinking that
their job is to talk to each other right
rather than to adjudicate what
constitutes science on the basis of
rules that are actually pretty well
understood and so I am NOT arguing that
we should be spending our time on this
but I'm arguing that their failure means
that a small amount of investment in
just getting our terminology even
straight so that when we make a claim we
are you know when physicists use the
word theory right for a hypothesis they
upend biologists who are saying actually
when we say yeah Darwinism is a theory
we made something very close I
appreciate but you have to understand
people get into this argument over
Darwinism because they're afraid of it's
absurd god yes okay I have a different
problem which is that in general when
physics isn't moving people aren't
getting more adventurous
who they're listening to they're staying
with the same Pope's sure so I could
turn to Karl Popper yeah or I could turn
to Ludacris and I don't know whether
you're familiar with the lyrics to the
song get out the way
now of course okay so my feeling is you
should say them for my audience who may
be somewhat less familiar I'm an old guy
I can't remember the lyrics exactly
however my feeling is strongly that we
should be following Ludacris rather than
Karl Popper because I don't have time
for this
no you do have time for it for the
following reason that it's a time-saver
now we are wasting time here
but that's not well that's not but I my
point is you've got suitors in the manor
so string the bow string the [ __ ]
boat single deploy but stringing the bow
involves just saying hey you string
theorists you have an interpretation
you're not theorists there was a guy
named julian schwinger who was fineman's
rival and came up with his version of
what we call renormalization theory to
get answers out of quantum
electrodynamics and he had an epigram
for a book that he had to write because
nobody was taking him seriously and the
epigram was if you can't join them beat
the beat them yeah mm-hmm so my feeling
is is that I could spend the rest of my
life trying to get their attention and
saying oh pretty please listen to this
thing that I've got I'm also just sick
of them I mean I'm just I'm sick of the
critique I'm sick of the discussions I'm
sick of the same people getting trotted
out over and over again I'm bored sure
and we're all bored if so my feeling is
let's do non boring things right but
your work okay I still don't get it we
will get there hopefully but your work
in the end will predict things in the
fuze physical universe that will allow
us to tell whether or not you got it
right well when you say you got it right
the most important person in this
regards is not Karl Popper is probably
Dirac in his 1963 Scientific American
article where he specifically points to
the instantiation of a theory
which is effectively not only the suit
but how it has been tailored okay so you
could have a suit that has been miss
tailored and it will not agree with
experiment the way the suit will not fit
the person who's intended to wear it on
the other hand that doesn't tell you
anything much about the suit it tells
you about the tailor so when you have an
invalidation part of the problem is is
that you've been validated the instance
oh rather than the class believe me for
one thing one of the reasons that I
spend time in philosophy of science land
is that I believe that all of the things
that we learned from the simpler fields
do not apply well to biology because the
complexity causes you to falsify true
things on the basis that that complexity
always provides edge cases which don't
agree and so if you take a very narrow
PAP aryan view you constantly think
things that are actually true are false
and this actually dovetails well with
popper himself who initially was not a
fan of adaptive thinking well very
strong preparing and miss readings of
popper but again my point is you are in
a luxurious position let's say with your
telomere theory and with the trade-offs
and the instantiation of antagonistic
pleiotropy as we discussed in episode 19
which is the point is okay I just
predicted something from first
principles inside of molecular biology
using only evolutionary arguments so fu
mhm
right right exactly whew is fun because
he doesn't want it I don't love having
another philosophy of science I'd rather
talk about do we have the ability to
validate to explore to refine and again
you know I want I talk around science
all the time either we're talking about
pedagogy we're talking about what is a
good foreign technology we're talking
about does it play by the rules we're
talking talk about everything other then
the mind-bending gut-wrenching
life-affirming soul elevating stuff
that'll get you high as a kite so I
would rather spend time
on like the majesty of the world then
talking about some goddamn philosopher
of science and whether or not I dotted
my eyes and crossed my teeth
totally yeah but I think your string
theory community is busy razzle-dazzle
with something that doesn't really merit
there today are so weak at this point it
is so past their sell-by date and not
because of the string theory it is the
string theory program which is let me
tell you don't worry we've got this
everyone else is an idiot we're smart
and anything else that anybody says
we're gonna declare as string theory
anyway if it's true so we got this my
feeling is you just wasted people's time
depending upon how we count based in
people's lives wasted crews lives
careers you spent the entire credibility
budget of the theoretical physics
community on a baby-boomer vanity
project move over it's enough totally
and I don't know if you would agree with
this exactly but I would say look the
reason that this happens in every field
and it's completely maddening with the
strings theorists but it's not totally
unique is that there is no mechanism
whereby a school of thought that has run
out of power to explain new things can
be dislodged right the fact that the
grant money keeps coming in or the jobs
keep getting bored there is something
which is money like for example there
was a death of a very rich person in
Chicago which I think was left at the
Poetry Foundation right so hundreds of
millions became available remember
poetry
yeah okay if you had hundreds of
millions to disintermediate strength
there you could do it in an afternoon
sure but my point would be the way to
deal with this so it doesn't keep
happening is on the front end and
frankly I'm not even sure I didn't get
this from you but if instead of allowing
the field the school of thought that is
the most promising at the moment to take
over the field at which point it becomes
impossible to design fails if you kept
the second-best school of thought alive
at all times so it the point that a
school of thought has failed it has its
natural replacement ready to go the
movie in a better position but let's
let's be
we're gonna end up in one more of these
diversion discussions which I can't
stand but here's the real deal
with respect to the string theorists
were smarter than the general
relativists they were more creative
string theory gave them some place to
demonstrate that they were smarter and
more creative okay yep as a result the
smart creative people went into an area
that turned out not to work now it's not
to say that some portion of it won't
will not be salvageable because it was
real work of a mathematical type but
part of the problem is how do I figure
out how to rationalize giving money to
people who are not as good as the top
people who've all rallied around
something uh-huh and so you have a
chicken and egg problem now let me just
say very clearly that this is not this
is like a peer-review problem this is a
science is social this is like selecting
for people with high emotional
intelligence some of us have high
emotional intelligence across a fair
spectrum and then it may be limited
somewhere else but we try not to use our
emotional intelligence when we're doing
science because it screws up our science
because in fact science isn't about like
anything that you want to pre assign it
to sometimes it works in teams sometimes
the team is the problem
it's whatever goddamn works and in
essence being able to say shut up to
people who have like a no [ __ ]
policy I keep hearing about our
department as a no [ __ ] policy it's
like great you wouldn't participated in
20th century physics next you know let's
just let's just say it's straight you
know what policy projected over a pass
that we all know who the heroes were oh
my god Newton was mean to me you know
now he doesn't have a job yeah okay well
you've just showed us I I would not send
my child to a university that announced
that it had in no [ __ ] policy on the
faculty I might say I don't want to
tolerate assholic behavior yep or unfair
behavior sure but like hard nosed yeah
no I mean you've been making this point
forever
first place I heard you make it was with
reference to medicine and your point was
very frequently the doctor you want is
an ornery son of a [ __ ] that they're
the people who will end up with our
first child was delivered by the ornery
son of a [ __ ] in a OBGYN practice who
saved us from the doctor we loved yeah
give me the son of a [ __ ] no exactly no
the person the person who makes sense
tells you what's really going on I don't
have to have tea with that person I got
my kid home from the hospital safe
frankly I'd actually rather have tea
with them because well maybe they make
some kind of sense maybe but nonetheless
all right we're bogged down what I want
to extract we're obviously not gonna get
to everything today but okay
you've got rollers and protractors right
rulers and protractors means something
these are tools for unpacking a system
the system is the universe and my sense
is that you play some kind of a game and
the game is like how many categories and
tools do I need before there's no
residual that I can't explain about the
observed right that's how I know when
the game is over right that's how I know
when this is well actually to be blunt
about it the really weird thing about my
theory again my theory in my own concept
I can't get into yours is you know
you're what 30 trillion cells 60
trillion cells you know the number keeps
changing I would say the current
estimates that could be such an easy
catch I know but 30 trillion is here 32
yeah okay how did that result and and
what 250 adult cell types a estimate as
as far as we know as far as we know okay
that all started from a single
fertilized egg which is I mean it
doesn't get better than this now
okay so miracle so how does that thing
have the information largely to become
you well it didn't
that's a process of unpacking the
consequences of a very simple seeming
initial object I have an innocuous
fertilized egg what could it possibly
become nobody way to ever guess that it
would become you right from first
principles right so that was part of
what I was trying to do with with a
theory of everything is like is there
anything that unpacks into something
that has the richness of our world is
there anything with almost no evidence
structure whose consequence is us
because there's tons of evidence
structures ok that's beautiful I've
never heard you say that before but it
dovetails exactly ok so in this case for
example that simple hairband where you
shrink the radius of that little tube
down to an infinitesimal amount you know
generates a paper towel core that falls
into two pieces turning that into the
analog of space-time is wrapping that
hairband in some way around the towel
core so that it goes around once right
you've lost me the towel core I thought
all rulers that could go at any point so
just move the bit of the hairband up so
though if you put the hairband on the
towel right roll then you can you could
mark every space and then you could move
it up and down and that would tell you
which rules and you can move it up over
here and down over there so it's got a
big ruler at this power up and small but
the idea is that each point on the
hairband only goes through one ruler
which is represented as old the the
space of possible rulers each point on
the band intersects exactly one point on
the tube one point of the longitudinal
lines on the tube every point in the
hairband only knows through one line
along the length wise direction of the
two yeah okay
that's a choice of a particular ruler
the line along that tube is the choice
of all possible rulers so you can order
any ruler you want from Amazon will
customize it yeah okay I want this ruler
for this point this ruler for that point
okay
okay now imagine that you had physics
that was happening not on the hairband
but on the tube
and which like you could ask for the
temperature gradients across the tube
maybe part of the tube is warm part of
the tube is cold and the only thing
you're going to record is what the
temperature was like at that point on
the tube in the various measure at that
point that the hairband was around the
tube yeah that is effectively the new
use of the space-time metric we knew
about rulers and we knew about
protractors but we don't have a model in
which that is a periscope importing
information from the tube back to the
hairband so the game then is what is the
minimally complex geometric structure
that provides you enough richness that
you can get to all of the states you
need with a simple description of sort
of let me just test to see whether or
not I understood you in my case what I
would say is that the hairband has
enough data so the hairband is like the
the fertilized a yeah has enough data to
build the tube which is tell me about
the space of all rulers I could have at
every point on the hairband yeah
measuring the tangent directions then on
the hairband
now that the hairband is generated the
paper towel core now I do physics on the
paper towel core like it can have fields
objectively stuff that roam around on
the towel core that are natural for the
towel core and I say well can I perceive
all of that no you can only perceive the
part that's along the hairband so and
then the ideas that were fooled in my
story into thinking that the physics is
all happening along the hairband which
is in our case the four-dimensional
world but the physics is actually
weirdly happening on this fourteen
dimensional auxiliary structure which is
the analog of the toilet paper or the
the paper towel core and we're only
sampling the part through the periscope
of putting the hairband around at one
particular latitude across the
lines and logic now in some sense this
is my worst nightmare because I think
you're telling me that this is another
this is a better version of many worlds
that the particular hairband that
describes an interaction with the tube
is like the one world in the many
possibilities well if you wanted to go
that direction and I know I don't many
words many worlds is a very particular
quantum mechanical concept due to I
guess ever it was the popularizer of it
what I would say is in an observers
which is the structure that contains
both the hairband and the paper towel
pour yep ice I enjoy that to being like
you're going to attend a soccer game or
a basketball game and you have stands
and you have the pitch and so the stands
are where you perceive what's going on
in the pitch and the pitch is like the
towel core the toilet that the paper
towel core the cardboard and the stands
are like the hairband and so you're only
sampling some of what's going on from
every particular like you and I went to
the same game yeah but we saw different
things because you were seated on the
floor and I'm up in the bleachers and
that I get the part of the many-worlds
thing that drives well the pain that I
want to make sure isn't lurking here I
mean and if it I'm just trying to say
that I don't see many universes I see
one observers and the one observers is a
more complicated or more rich structure
and I want to say I don't think it's
that difficult to understand yeah in
which you would be confused if you
thought like I'm the only person that
exists and I happened to be sitting here
in the stands and you saw that guy get
pushed across the way and I didn't see
him get pushed was like you have a
different view of the action you saw
things I never saw there's more going on
than I could perceive in my seat I get
that and that I like that you know the
game took place there was one reality of
the game and there were any
number of possible edits based on where
you work there were an infinite number
of places you could I like the cabinets
that's what happened in the first matrix
movie that they actually mocked it up in
3d and then they only took one of the
possible camera angles for the CGI
scenes I didn't know that yeah so the
question though is will your hypothesis
in my world theory in your world will it
rescue us from the idea that all of
these things are happening that every
game took place and you just happened to
be so you're the thing is is that most
of what you hear about discussed by the
four or five Talking Heads you may have
heard of from physics yeah is is that
they keep trying to blow your mind with
the same I know
repetitive quantum mechanical stuff so
it's always about many worlds it's about
entanglement right about the collapse of
the wavefunction the shortage bah blah
blah let's not go there initially let's
fix the geometry underneath both general
relativity this is great what I'm what
I'm hoping my prediction is that if you
do that if you fix the geometry then
many worlds goes away well because in
part what you're calling a world yeah
maybe a perfect a particular way of
placing the hairband around the core and
yes there an infinite number of ways
placing the hairband around the paper
towel core that doesn't bug me right the
thing that bugs me is that they all
happen and that somebody thinks that
that's an elegant solution to a problem
when it's maximally in elegance but they
all have to talk to Sean Carroll about
that that is he's a believer David
Deutsch oh I know but anyway I'm really
hoping that your thing blows that out of
the water because I'm sick of hearing
explanations like that well again you
know my point is is that within the
paradigm that our forefathers left us in
this case maybe Bohr and Einstein we we
are doomed
to infinitely blow our minds on the same
set of points without progress and I'm
tired yeah yeah once is enough 100 times
is pretty good even if a on your on your
hundred thousandth time it the electron
goes through both slits you shut them
doc yeah well everybody does need to go
through that but that's the step should
be the stuff a conical wave is the part
of it it's a wave that's a wave it's a
wave all right
sometimes the wave gets measured as a
particle a concentrated wave can feel
like a particle but it's a goddamn wave
nice ah that's excellent you heard it
here first all right so we should
probably figure out how to close this up
obviously my sense is that what you have
described is exactly what I was hoping
you would do which is the sort of
intuitive version of what it is that you
do and what the sort of thing is that
you think you found and then there's a
there's probably 20 chalkboards full of
math that mirrors what you're saying and
the added value for most of us for the
math on the board is probably zero or
near zero right the point is if the math
is right then what you have just
described is likely to be true and that
that would resolve many of the things
that cause us to get look up what I'm if
you wanted at that level what I would
say is Einstein told us take four
degrees of freedom put four rulers and
six protractors on top of them which is
the right number yeah call that
space-time and space-time generates
curvature and curvature is measured by
the stuff floating around in the system
so you set the stuff floating around in
the system the matter and the energy
equal to the amount of curvature that
comes out of the rulers and protractors
and you're done yeah if you'd like the
augmentation here is not so fast what if
the fields that is the stuff the matter
and the energy bosons and the fermions
are dancing across all possible rulers
and all possible protractors and what
you're doing is you're sampling the
rulers and the protractors on one
particular choice in this case the hare
around the core and along that you're
pretending that that is the world and
that's the universe and that's us and
our fate and when did the world begin
and in some sense you're asking you've
learned to ask an entire set of
narcissistic questions based on your
particular perception of the observers
and the observers is about the pitch and
the stands being part of the stadium if
you learned to stop asking questions
about your experience of the game and
you ask well what game took place
yesterday how many people how many
different things did they see and what
took place on the pitch independent of
what I was able to perceive is taking
place at my seat you know then you start
to understand like nobody would talk
about the many games hypothesis where
every single person experienced a
different game last night you know and
they're in their ways in which the
stands interact with the pitch because
everybody's yelling like missmiss during
a free throw right yeah and so you also
have to deal with the fact that there's
a way in which people who aren't
supposed to be part of the game become
part of the game
no I love this that the indefinitely
large number of different observations
of the game do not imply more than one
game there's a lot more game than
physics currently thinks is going on
that's my belief all right well that's
very cool and although I still feel like
five minutes after our discussion is
over I will begin to lose track of what
I understand at this moment I feel like
I'm Way it's also just like this sucks
because I've always wanted to talk to
you about what it is that I do and what
it is that I think and like when I've
discovered something and the thing that
I don't understand and maybe this is
something I should ask you is I think
about the complexity of like Seinfeld or
The Sopranos or Game of Thrones or Harry
Potter or the Lord of the Rings
everybody remembers so many different
pieces of information and when it comes
to like particles they're like now dude
that's so hard I'm saying hey I'll tell
you the part of it that's hard and
remembering that
there's an electron a muon and the Tau
particle is not the hard part no I get
that I think there's something I mean I
find it almost tragic because I think
you are working you know I'm not in a
position to judge but I do have the
sense that knowing you and knowing what
you have sounded like over all of these
decades as you've worked on this I have
the sense that you're very likely to be
right right I would bet strongly in
favor of you being right it's
interesting if that's true we should be
able to make some money I'm not gonna
bet against it no but it's an
interesting question right when you ask
people to quantify just how like it's
very cheap for somebody say that bozo oh
yeah like right he came up with
something outside of the university haha
okay it's like well quantify just how
how ridiculous right is short are you
ready short me at ten thousand to one
odds right cuz like I'll put up a I'll
put I'll put a thousand bucks at ten
thousand to one odds you are you
interested sure no I it's it seems like
it should be and for some reason the
universe doesn't support this which
indicates to people I don't have time
for this nonsense right it's a quality
control well they control it yeah but
but here's the thing I I do find there
to be something tragic which is that I
know that you have been adventuring on
your own frontier for all of this time I
know that you want company because I
mean I have the same experiences that my
frontier is easier right I can bring
people to my frontier because we all
have experience of the biota and it
makes sense right
I think the thing that you really don't
remember yeah is how hard the cognitive
stuff is in this realm
and it is not for lack of interest it is
for the experience of getting nowhere
right the experience of getting nowhere
and the thing is we all have skills that
look absolutely impossible I mean your
Twitter feed reddit are full of people
doing things that you would not think
possible if you didn't have video
evidence of the fact that some human
being did it in front of a camera right
and the thing is if you have even one of
those skills mm-hmm then you also know
that eh you couldn't describe
to somebody else how you do it you could
give them some insight maybe there's
some part of this which I actually just
sort of relieved
yeah which is I know that there are 20
amino acids and I know that there are
four nucleotides I know there's a sugar
phosphate backbone yeah I know that I
need heritability differential success
in variation in order to generate like
this stuff is on speed-dial right now
it's not unspayed dial like I understand
the really tough stuff yeah I don't have
the Krebs cycle on speed dial
yeah neither do i okay but I don't
understand the extent to which people
like when I when I showed the hopf
fibration on Joe Rogan yeah there was a
moment in which people were actually
able to see a non-trivial principal
fiber bundle and I said this is the most
important object in the universe because
it allows you to see the arena in which
fundamental physics gets played so the
basis of all reality takes place in a
world of objects that look like this and
here's the only one that you can
actually fully see right yep
and to me like if you told me this and I
was doing anything else imagine I'm a
cashier you could not have got me to
stop thinking about that to the point
that I actually understood right no I
get this but what I think is not obvious
and I mean look you're either gonna take
my word for it or not is that there's
something about the cognitive trade-offs
yeah I believe that this ship sailed for
me a long time ago and it turned me into
a kind of remote spectator of the sort
of stuff you're talking about whereas if
I walk into a tropical forest I start
seeing stuff it pops at me right I know
what to pay attention how to think about
it I know what these pre try to imagine
that you're in a tropical forest you see
a bunch of small insects carrying what
appeared to be parts of leaves that look
like sales right okay yeah I if I came
in there I would say whoa what do you
know about these leafcutter ants if
somebody else comes into physics they're
like dude I saw the craziest thing there
were like six legs on them and they were
carrying like sales I would say oh
they're leaf cutter ants I would talk
about leaf and then the person would
come back and the next week they'd say
dude I saw this crazy thing there were
six legs and they were carrying these
pieces of leaves I would say we had this
discussion we put our hands
right
no I look I get it your your confusion
about what's going on with the rest of
us and it's not all of the rest of us
but what some of the rest of us is well
obviously organic so this is this is
part of my confusion one of the things
that we could also talk about is what is
it like to see the rest of the world as
crazy all the time so I'm not sure where
I fit in this analogy am I one of the
crazy ones who doesn't get the half a
physics half crazy okay so like there's
nothing in your brain that couldn't do
the one day investment in mathematical
and mathematical physics to put you in a
very strong position to understand what
the problems are that we're trying to
solve I would love that to be true I
have a feeling it's false and I want to
tell you why I think it's false okay
okay I have a very beautiful guitar our
grandfather got it for me many many
years ago decades in fact really I just
got a cheap one from Yamaha that he gave
me so obviously loved you more yeah yeah
well he desperately wanted me to have
what you have has the ability to make
music and I've carried this thing every
time I've moved I've lovingly packed it
up yeah put it on the wall I've taken I
don't know how many lessons I have never
gotten to the point where I can play a
single song that sounds good to me and I
have a feeling if I could get to that
one thing and I've even heard you say
look you know if you tune the things to
slide you can in a few hours yep you
know I've heard you say it's it's not
true okay
okay and my point is I feel weird about
this I actually feel ashamed about it
because I so desperately want that thing
and I do not have the module I clearly
don't and it breaks my heart and I've
sort of gotten over it but the fact is
it's like okay I'm very good at English
I'm known to be good in English I do not
have a gift for other languages I've
tried I've lived in Latin America and I
have sucky Spanish that you know it's
enough so I can travel with it I can
talk to people and I can have good
conversations have you tried well let's
put it this way
there's no level of not that good
because I'm at the wrong language but
every Spanish had a reach
Spanish should be in reach for me I
don't know that in other words not a
hard language sorry depends you know it
really depends if you for example find
the burden of grammatical gender to be
very high just the way some people find
to clefts to be too difficult for
reading music one clef doesn't confuse
them because they can learn it there
might be an obstacle so what I'm trying
to say is is that I know for example
that you have not tried Malay or bus
Indonesia which I know to be different
character illogically from Spanish right
look I'm not disagreeing with that there
may be a language out there that if I
hit upon it boom and there might be an
instrument out there or there might even
be a technique at which I could approach
the instrument I've been trying to learn
to play I wonder if I put stickers on
your guitar and tune and show and bought
you a tuner and then took five songs
that you really liked and told you
exactly which strings to pluck right
maybe yeah maybe but what I'm telling
you is that the intuition of somebody
who literally picked up the guitar and
taught at home just to himself sat down
at the piano and taught it to himself
has learned passable useful parts of I
don't know six languages or something
like that your sense is that these
things are over complicated by people my
sense is that people confuse mastery for
being reasonably well acquainted with
something yeah and they are usually
unwilling they are psychologically
blocked when they are told that's
something that they've always wanted to
do is within reach yeah an understanding
that they have to go at about it
slightly differently than they were
expecting right but here's the thing
okay I have a table that I made no okay
I am able to do this in my head I can
figure out what I need to buy okay I can
figure out how to deploy the tools I
have even if I don't have the tools that
would be optimal I can correct for
errors that I didn't see coming it's
very intuitive
and I know that it isn't that way for
other people it just doesn't work that
way so what I have forgotten and I have
to remind myself of is that that
intuition about how to do it is housed
in someplace that I can't even access
what's going on
right I'm conscious of what I'm doing at
one level I mean there's a whole other
level at which you know I can I can put
together the table in one way in my head
and I can sort of stress test it and see
whether those joints are gonna work and
I can refashion it it's not something it
seems simple to me but it isn't simple
likewise you know riding an electric
unicycle and not falling off that was
recent enough for me that I know how
hard it is to get on that thing so
explain something to me yeah
if I tell most people there are four
forces they can't remember the four
fundamental forces yeah but they will
remember John Paul George and Ringo
mm-hmm but this this is this parts easy
some of us learn based on whether
something sticks to something we already
know right so forces isn't so hard
because you know let's put it this way I
suffered through enough chemistry and I
wouldn't say I suffered through physics
but I had the material that I had to get
through in order to go and study biology
and those things interact with the
forces in question right so I I have
things that when we talk about those
forces I can stick them on to and they
last because it actually builds out what
I'm capable of
in the case of the other stuff that
you're talking about these things
actually are like thought Islands right
there's nothing near them
right and you know sometimes you bridge
this gap right you say ruler protractor
rulers and protractors obviously those
are things that exist for me and they
have meaning because obviously you know
hey when I do carpentry I'm doing trig
and so angles that's native to me but
there are a lot of these islands of
thought that are almost impossible for
me to build
then make it last because the brain
takes apart that which isn't interacting
with other things and so anyway this may
be a defect of mine it may be a strength
that has a cost I don't know but what
I'm telling you is that the experience
of confronting the material and trying
to acquire enough of it is not
successful it's only reality my friend
it is you're hardly the only person who
suffers from this I think and this is
the interesting part of it that you're
all crazy
I find all of you completely insane and
I can't express to you how frustrating
it is alot bet that like people remember
the Heisenberg uncertainty principle
they remember that Schrodinger is
[ __ ] cat and if you say muon it
doesn't stick the cat the double slit
maybe it's they want to know about
entangle they want to know about many
worlds they can't remember that there's
a muon or for example you know they say
well we're carbon-based life-forms so I
say okay in a carbon atom you got a
bunch of protons and neutrons stuck
together tell me something what do like
charges do when they're very close to
you
oh they repel okay well why am I not
exploding and obliterating you I don't
know why not
something about the strong force yeah I
don't grasp this I don't understand like
right now you're seated in a chair yep
gravity you can see me yeah
electromagnetism I don't blow you up
strong force yeah that's three out of
four forces just for us to have this
conversation yeah if there's then if I
say to you name members of The Rolling
Stones
you'll name more members of the Rolling
Stone than then you can name forces or
particles or anything it's just it's
very weird that people have decided that
they're blocked because I can tell that
the data needed to store this is so
slight
oh you think it is I know you think it
is but what you don't understand you
know do you know how much I want to play
the guitar no you have no idea no
because you don't see me playing the
guitar do you know why no cuz I've spent
hundreds of hours and what I've got for
it because frustration and an object
that requires that I take delicate care
of it that follows me from one state to
the other right it's not a lack of
desire to play the guitar it's not a
lack of desire to understand what it is
that you do to in the guitar you have a
ten I can tune the guitar can you place
strings two three and four not the one
closest to your leg but the next one the
one after that and the one after that
what do you mean can I play this can you
pluck those three strings out of the six
strings across your guitar sure okay
that's the major chord known as G yep
okay I've played chords okay doesn't get
me anywhere I never get to a song what
songs do you like you know what songs I
like you like Johnny be good sure play
Johnny be good okay
Johnny be good can be played with the
chords G C and D and all you need is
those three string so you can cut the
other three strings on your guitar all
right cut them here's cut week just cut
it guys cut them just cut them sure
that's Gwen if you find a glass that
isn't like this curved glass yeah but is
instead a straight edge glass yeah you
dragged that glass across those three
strings and you put it at the fifth fret
position which gives you the C chord or
the seventh fret position which I can
put a sticker on your thing then I can
color code the stickers to Johnny be
good yeah okay
just I might even work yeah my claim is
might even work might even work but
here's the thing so I'm constantly
trying to emphasize to Zach that they
the gap between knowing how something is
done and knowing how to do it is often a
huge gap right we you know you could
read every book that has ever been
written on how to play tennis mm-hm and
he was lock onto the court as a [ __ ]
sucking novice who couldn't that's not
what I'm talking about what I'm talking
about ink utility to play
Johnny be good your first day and it
won't be your favorite version of trying
to be good but if you have the
experience as I did like holy cow I just
got myself through a song that I love
and I don't know anything all I did was
follow these rope directions now I want
to understand what directions did I
follow sure well if this works I'm gonna
I'm gonna kick myself hope so why didn't
I do this at 20
I've been available my number it's not
like I haven't asked you and we've
actually sat down to do it it's never
worked so maybe maybe you've got a
better method or maybe I'm more mature
and can handle what you're trying to
tell me but there is something where you
know I mean look it's just trade-offs
man it's a trade-off so I'm really good
at some stuff in it got some weird cost
there are things that I'm not good at
for example when I tried to read the
Lord of the Rings I got completely
thrown by the number of names and places
and characters I didn't care anything
about totally turned me off yeah I think
that there may be things that turn you
off in this process I'm not saying that
you weren't blocked
I'm saying that there are situations in
which you're trying to tell Ray Charles
would you look at the beauty of this
painting and he's like I'm not getting
it and you're not getting these blind
right so there are there are real
blockages yeah then there are imaginary
blockages where you're like you're
saying oh my god I'm blind and
somebody's saying like okay just open
your eyes oh oh this is amazing
okay no actually I like this because
undoubtedly yeah undoubtedly the things
that blocked me are a mixture of these
two things right right there are some
real blocks that may be impenetrable and
there are some other blocks that are
just my giving up too early right and
it's very difficult to disentangle them
because from my perspective they feel
alike they'd all feel like impenetrable
blocks all I'm trying to suggest is that
the there are things in physics that are
very difficult to do that are very
frustrating and I can I can empathize
with the issue that that these things
create problems and blockages people
then invoke that to talk about the fact
that even though they're super curious
about Heisenberg's answer
any principle and the measurement
problem and something they heard about
many worlds they don't know the first
thing about what is the stuff that our
world is made of just like the laundry
list so you know there's Hamlet to play
and the beauty of the English language
and whether or not one understands every
sentence there's also just a question of
you know are you aware that a philia and
Hamlet are in the same play but here's
the thing this is this is a good example
what I'm talking about
you have taught me that stuff okay okay
and it did sort of stick enough that
it's actually in one of the lectures
that I used to deliver to my students
okay where I showed them the
fundamentals the fermions and the bosons
etc I have lost track I actually at this
moment couldn't distinguish between I
know that one of these things is forces
and one of these things as objects but I
couldn't remember which is which and the
reason for that is because in the
learning process
this particular piece of knowledge does
not get reinforced so even though I had
it at one time enough to teach it to
people who hadn't heard it I have now
lost it it's gone okay now would it be
easy for me to you know to get back to
it sure it would just take a little
refresher but you've got a durable
heuristic like for example fermions we
have a Fermi paradox which people know
about which is why don't we know about
anybody else in the universe yeah
well those alien beings would be made of
matter so maybe the idea is that
fermions are made of matt cool okay so
that's an it's like a little sticky
thing and then you could say right oh
shoot or is it boughs of the clown
because he's a boson and bozos made it
matter now I've confused myself again
right all right I get it but I don't
know I guess look I'll be honest there's
a sadness that I have which is that I
[Music]
guess I get to visit everybody else's
field and people give all sorts of
reasons why they're super interested in
things that I care about without ever
wanting to make the trek and in fact
like a little bit what I saw with the
geometric unity stuff when I released
episode 19 which was the episode with
you about telomeres and the Grider
laboratory
the interaction between you and the
Grider laboratory with respect to the
prediction that laboratory mice would be
the ones with ultra elongated telomeres
and not mice in general having yeah
people loved the story and that story
stuck to their ribs I have people coming
up to me about that story when it comes
to let's say geometric unity I said lots
of things that were quite explicit and
it's been fascinating to see people
saying well he didn't write a paper so
he can't have any idea what he's done
which is nonsense complete nonsense
mm-hmm I believe that yeah I'm just
saying that part of the problem is is
that the world has such an inferiority
complex about physics and math it's like
the sum total of every middle-school
teacher in high school teacher who
convinced people that they sucked at
this thing which is a universal human
birthright is that we've got a planet
that is traumatized by mathematics and
anything that has the threat that it
could become math or that we will be
asked what can you compute this
determinant of this matrix I can't
remember the formula for determined okay
it's we're talking about universal human
trauma with several exceptions who are
the mathematicians and physicists yeah I
believe that and you know I deal with a
much more mundane version of this which
is whether or not you think you care
about biology or are any good at
thinking about it has a lot to do with
whether or not you had a lame-ass
biology teacher who did force you to
learn the krebs cycle for no good reason
right so a lot of people have biology
trauma over stuff they didn't need to
learn in the first place and so you know
in the classroom one of the things that
I did was try to convince people who
thought they had no interest in this
thing that everything they cared about
depended on it and that it wasn't as
hard as people were making it out to be
so I know I've sat in your chair I've
given the speech but having given us
well you haven't sat in my class
obviously this is the sad part yeah but
you know what's actually going on no
idea I mean literally I am so
mystified right by the asymmetry am i
right we've done better today than prior
instances that we've done 45 minutes an
hour's worth of I'm not sure I honestly
I have that sense all right but here's
what I think happens okay there's
something about this environment the
fact that you and I are talking together
with some awareness that other people
are going to see it the change is the
power dynamics it changes our ability to
step into a highly didactic framework I
don't know what it is but I do have the
sense this doesn't sound like our normal
conversations it doesn't sound that far
from them but that just maybe even just
the simple fact of cameras being they
may forced it I wasn't aware that there
was I just have the general sense of
everybody cares about something that
nobody seems to care about and that's
confusing to me it's like I don't know
what Brian Greene and Sean Carroll and
Neil deGrasse Tyson are doing and michio
kaku I don't understand like some so
much of the time I'm just thinking like
you spent all your time talking about
these few things there's all of this
beautiful stuff that we essentially
never talked about you've got huge
numbers of people who buy these books
who don't seem to know anything about
the world and I don't I don't grasp what
kind of dance this is why are you going
to a lecture about string theory or
about many worlds when you have no idea
what a muon is well first of all I'm not
look people are frustrating me I would
say Neil deGrasse Tyson is an exception
because I think he's doing something
different but you are looking at a group
of people who I believe are making a
living at least in part by saying trippy
things well I like saying trippy things
yeah saying trippy things in making a
living are two great things no no that's
not what I'm saying no what I'm saying
is that they have specialized on the art
of saying trippy things which requires
them in some sense not to simplify them
or to acknowledge what they don't know I
don't really understand
this again I would say that they are
choosing to say trippy things that are
highly repetitive in an not very
informative ways in ways that leave
people yeah I'll tell you what it
strikes me is there's something I call
wealth porn and the New York Times for
example might do a story about people
who are so obscenely rich that you both
pity them and envy them simultaneously
yeah okay
and they'll describe a party which is
incredibly de botched which causes you
to pity them and incredibly exciting and
mimetic which causes you to wish that
you'd been invited this is in some sense
what we're talking about which is like
science porn music sport Wow I both
realize how stupid I am but I also got a
taste of the brilliance that you were in
part whereas I'm talking about goddamn
paper towel cores and hair bands right
because I'm actually talking or or
showing you the hopf fibration and
people seem to want to sign up for this
repetitive abusive relationship with a
small number of mind blowers that the
community allows to speak it doesn't
bring the world to understand we've got
to get another accelerator because we
have to know the answer to have the
story you know it's extractive it's
actually robbing the field of the
pressure to build the accelerator to
discover the next thing that actually
makes a difference by basically feeding
people a diet of maraschino cherries
yeah although I would say that ever
since I've started talking about like
the hopf fibration and how I came hopf
fibration was almost almost a hundred
years ago discovered that was 1923 I was
delighted to see Sean Carroll doing a
program recently on geometry like the
mind-blowing aspects of geometry and
somebody will eventually do geometric
quantization to understand how the
Heisenberg principle comes out of the
curvature of an object technically
called a line bundle or a pre quantum
line
but that that situation is like we're
waiting and waiting and waiting when
they finally get around to it when the
designated few finally get around to
saying okay well this is something we
actually did do as opposed to all the
stuff that we claim that we did that we
didn't actually pull off everyone will
say yeah yeah that's great you know see
they're doing it and it's just like I'll
want to know well why did we spend 50
years talking about entanglement I look
obviously I don't get something but to
me and then this is like an interesting
segue if you want to get out of this
what is it like to live on a planet
where everyone appears completely
batshit insane well a small number of us
are now having that experience on many
different and that's right and and what
is also interesting is is that if I told
you you know four years ago you're
living through a revolution and it's
going to turn kinetic and you were
quoting pop read not pop or Pinker no no
no Steven Pinker says yeah this is the
best time to be alive like yes because
he doesn't have a potential violence
term yep you know like you have
potential energy Angela absol okay I
guarantee you that when Steven Pinker
finally realizes he will not first of
all identify the fact that he was wrong
and second of all everyone will say okay
well I'm a pink Aryan and I work you
know you have to talk about what he
called the you know the sword in the
sheath problem okay well it wasn't that
this other thing no it's like we are
going to over and over find the same
voices and it doesn't matter how wrong
they've been and it doesn't matter the
fact you've got like somebody like Nasim
to leb who's almost insufferable yep I
mean I said is it because I think of
being a long-term friend of his yeah the
man's right no he's right and I mean
I've but we know you we won't go we
won't go to the guy who's right right
won't go to the guy who was early we
won't go to the guy who's I think to
Levis is the right example we won't go
to Talab because he's insufferable he's
insufferable not he's aggressive in any
way it is not even an argument as to why
you wouldn't go to him I mean the guy
has told he's called me a dangerous loon
on Twitter Yeah right and I still think
of him as one of the people I look to
for insights is rightly tolerate you see
the thing is is that I can say to seem
to love is a pain in the ass yeah right
right I'm not telling him anything he
doesn't know I don't think he's gonna
stop being my friend right you know the
issue though is pain in the ass you know
if I think about like why don't I go to
stefan molyneux stefan molyneux is not
wrong about everything it's not like
stefan molyneux gets up makes himself a
cup of coffee and I'll be wrong yeah
just says wrong things until he goes to
bed at night yeah
the danger of stefan molyneux is is that
he may have even started off being
reasonable but the world told him that
he was a lunatic for saying real things
and that started a process in his mind
where he didn't understand that in
trying to prove that he wasn't a lunatic
or wasn't a bastard or whatever yeah he
started advocating for a position that
was quite a bit stronger in my in my
understanding than simply saying hey
there are differences between widely
geographically separated groups that you
would expect on any continuous variable
and IQ is no different yeah that's a
very responsible statement that I
understand we'll get lots of people on
there fainting couches yeah okay I don't
want to go to stefan molyneux not
because he's wrong about that right I
don't want to go to him because of the
other stuff that he's gonna do people
are gonna claim the same thing about in
the scene yeah the problem is at the end
of the day you have to make a call yeah
as to when you're dealing with in a seam
and when you're dealing with a stefan
molyneux and you may even be wrong
well that's true though right and it's
but you know it's like I I can't get out
of the fact that stefan molyneux might
say new interesting things yeah there's
that there's no way to stop like
straight-up Nazis horrible you Genesis
all sorts of people have contributed to
the human condition
the most privileged person in the world
you know I mean wasn't wasn't there an
important
say Rothschild who was a an insect
specialist you know privilege may mean
that you actually get a chance to do
great science I think Sam Kohlberg was
it was royalty and did physics if I'm
not mistaken no I mean at some level
Darwin was a yeah dilettante who got on
the a ship in order to be you know high
class companion for I was born with us
silver he was and he did absolutely
stunningly good work and he was a great
guy and he could easily have been
forgotten right yes yeah but like at
some level we don't gravitate to the
voices and in particular like yours my
feeling is is that you were the first
person that I knew who could describe
the full craziness of this authoritarian
regressive mindset that was at Evergreen
that is now spilled out onto the entire
planet so you had front-row seats but
lots of people at Evergreen had
front-row seats now you had a very keen
mind to analyze it some people at
Evergreen at Kean mad minds to analyze
it the third thing you had was courage
and integrity to talk about it
so I remember talking about I got my
original education in having gone
through some of this postmodern nonsense
I hadn't understood some of the
refinements and modern as I'll twith the
basic version of it I had did not know
about all the ways in which had been
weaponized and and made hermetically
sealed unto itself when we started
trying to talk about this I remember
going to Sam Harris and saying Sam
something is happening at Evergreen and
you've got to plug in and I talked he
wasn't the only person I went to he was
the only person outside of this system
who grasped something of what the
madness was because it was not under you
know the thing that you may not
understand is that a lot of us who
weren't in a concentrated version of
this
yeah weren't able to even see what the
data was oh well I mean this is an
interesting moment to be having this
conversation because of course Heather
and I are having the weirdest and it's
not entirely positive experience where
you know we lived through this thing
some people got it quickly some people
got it slowly most people never got it
and suddenly because it's everywhere
it's now widely gettable which has the
most maddening aftertaste because I feel
like look we went through this
I was actually hunted in my own
neighborhood by people who I do not
believe could have been right you're
gonna be fine yeah you're white you're
gonna I do this with because it you came
from the Pacific Northwest I do this
with Kirk Kove Kurt Cobain and I say you
know yo what you know talk about
mountain mental illness it's crippling
you can end up blowing your head off
with a shotgun just like Kurt Cobain and
then I have the idea of the
intersectional answer that oh is he
white cuz I'll be fine yeah fine no
matter what no he's white because
nothing can nothing bad can happen
happens yeah but anyway yeah it's a it's
a very wellbut alienating experience
well to have seen it like that to have
articulated it to have been told you
were crazy to now have people calling me
to tell me oh you weren't right but your
point is you're not going to be made a
columnist at some important place
because you were early talking about
right and this is the thing with the
pendulum I mean look there's your
earliness which is before mine
and there's my earliness and I'm pissed
about my earliness not being recognized
because how much grief did I take right
now one thing I went through that I
don't know if you really went through it
was the dumb money versus the smart
money in 2008 hmm the dumb money
panicked when it saw Bear Stearns go
belly up the smart money said huh
that's just Bear Stearns those guys are
such losers that's not serious yeah and
then they freaked out when when the
Lehman Brothers goes under
AIG is next and suddenly they're like
holy [ __ ] we have a real problem in the
financial system okay was the dumb money
dumb when it saw the problem at Bear
Stearns and my claim is they are
treating you like the dumb money that
saw the problem early when it was Bear
Stearns yeah and somehow the cool kids
didn't know to freak out until much
later well the same thing happened in
physics right so the idea is that the
dumb physicists which included Sheldon
Glashow Nobel Prize winner and Richard
Fineman and a whole bunch of other
people who didn't go in for string
theory like you don't get the problem
with string theory you know I was like
are you kidding you're a child you know
and so the idea is that the smart kids
understood the string theory was gonna
be fine and then when string theory
finally got to issues about you know the
landscape and too many vacuo and all
this stuff they're like oh my god we've
got a problem with string theory now why
is it when the cool kids wake up that
there's still the smart kids right why
you made this point to me decades ago
which is that there is a degree of
earliness in which we never vindicate
the people who actually had it right
even though those are the voices that
are the most interesting getting it
right just before because you wave for
guaranteed when somebody gets it right
too early the danger is that they're
thinking for themselves mm-hmm
right and when somebody's thinking for
themselves it means that you can't get
them to sign up for the next
they're not gonna salute your flag when
you're not going to salute your flag for
the next flag that gets run up the
flagpole right and so the idea is that
you never win weirdly when you're too
early you knee up to be you know like
mad at Glacia so say you know it's
possible that this isn't just confined
to university campus yeah how
interesting are you saying that things
taught at university can actually spread
outside of university yes I am saying
good very well Diane welcome let the
other people at Vox know yes no it's
exactly that and you know I've been
trying to make this point about
the fact that all these failures that
don't look at all alike they all look
individual are really the same
phenomenon and that they're actually
telling us something about how to think
about such a phenomenon so you know
you've got deepwater horizon you've got
the financial collapse of 2008
you've got Fukushima you got Aliso
Canyon cover that you've got covin 19
and the probable lab leak that caused it
all of these things caused me now to
think okay I discover that some process
is afoot in the world right that is an
existential threat something goes wrong
that's very very bad but not nearly as
bad as it could have been right and so
we get lucky in all of these cases even
the worst of them we got luckily so far
so far and you can just extrapolate the
point is you're looking at a
distribution of catastrophes yes and we
are able to infer with the number of
these catastrophes we've had we're able
to infer the tale that you must survive
because and this is look this is the
hardest thing that I've had to do which
is to say we have a universal problem
with institutions and expertise that is
essentially everywhere yes and it has
one source and that one source is that
when you are not growing but your entire
society is built on growth every
institution will select for a wire to
claim that that's institution is fine
and should be kept afloat yeah right
like the idea is somebody says you know
in this department we're not really
doing anything we haven't done anything
for a number of years I think what
should probably happen is that I should
retire I should get my colleagues to
retire and we should hire a bunch of
people who are hostile to the ideas that
we've spent the last 15 years on right
like each does not exist that speech
doesn't while it may exist there may be
I'm not saying that nobody's ever given
it right like Eisenhower on his way out
says beware the military steals oh my
boot peace out folks okay so there's the
mic drop of Eisenhower yeah
but well what I believe is we have all
the wrong experts every single person
who's risen to the top of this system
should be expected unless their name is
Ralph Connery to be corrupt mm-hmm like
it's almost that bad maybe the
University at we ha go we have maybe we
have an expertise generating function
that selects for corruptness and then
we're shocked that all of these things
are failing off boy did you see this
pouchy thing the other Bentham asks so I
specifically said copiously everywhere
everywhere we are destroying the
credibility in science by pretending
that our problem to stock masks and
personal protective equipment is
actually the failure of masks to be
efficacious in stopping the spread of
this disease yeah I remember your exact
phraseology was what are the chances
that masks would not be at least
somewhat effective right in preventing
the spread and foul she says yeah that's
why we did it I'm just saying like okay
great time to lose your job and retire
from public life yes time for you to
lose your job and it's time for the rest
of us to go back to a tweet stream that
is only months old and say who got this
right let's let's take the totality of
people who were able to see the obvious
right right including this is going to
turn out to have been widely considered
to be the Wuhan lab yes of course
and everybody in officialdom is lying
and they should lose their jobs they
should lose their jobs the people who
got it right so that's the problem is
you can edit down you know how many
people got this thing right and the
point is well well but I get it right
let's be very clear about yeah
I don't mean to predict like this
definitely came from the Wuhan lab yeah
we don't know that okay because the
claim is the people who think this came
from the Wuhan lab are lunatics they're
anti Chinese yep the bigots did this to
that like okay shut the [ __ ] up
first of all yeah shut the [ __ ] up let's
look at the group of people who stood up
and will
to be your pretend bigots you bigots you
bastards
sons of [ __ ] it is time for you all
to lose your jobs to the people who
actually stood up and not only called
the fact that this was an important
consideration but said so in public
against the juggernaut of your
wall-to-wall defense of our involvement
with this goddamn Wuhan Lab but what the
hell is our situation with China is that
most of the people driving a luxury
automobile had a lot of their money come
from China in one form or another we've
got a bunch of Americans who are not
fundamentally interested in the American
project they're interested in their
second home or you know we're sending
their third kid through college or
whatever and those people are addicted
to China they want to do China the way
you know jazz musicians used to do
heroin it's essential for their being
able to function yeah and it's a gamble
they have gambled all of our futures
that gambled the West on a belief that
China will be obligated by its need for
us as a market to function as we will
make China a better China by
constructive engagement which means that
I will have a third home with a swimming
pool yeah and it's all a rationalization
yeah
and so if you edit down the world if you
say okay here's the entire population of
you know by the way you and I probably
have some percentage of our net worth
that comes from jobs from China right my
feeling is I don't want it I'd rather be
poorer and not be dependent on whoever
it was who massacred students in
Tiananmen Square . well it's a little
bit like the way evolutionary biology
has been disrupted by our belief that
reproductive success and fitness are
actually the same thing they're closely
related right
but being better off being wealthier is
not the same thing as being a richer and
so yes of course we would surrender a
substantial fraction of our wealth not
to have the gamble of being so dependent
on a nation that is so clearly hostile
to us at the level of fundamental
interests I would rather live on
and beans with an ability to think
freely and not have to parrot some
stupid-ass [ __ ] in order to keep my job
yeah right I really would rather have
rice and beans and if you would rather
have a luxury automobile and lied for a
living then we need a divorce yeah yeah
I absolutely absolutely agree with this
and now you know I'm not exactly sure
what we're seeing in our streets because
I'm pretty sure that anybody who is
hostile to our long-term well-being and
strength is certain to be happy about
the lunacy that is now threatening us
and so what I can't see is any reason
that they would not be attempting to
amplify it and the tools to do so would
appear to be ubiquitous yes so we are
now behind the 8-ball in our most
remarkable well yes and no I mean to be
blunt about it and to be horrible about
it
we are strangely what is left of what we
were and I know this because in some
sense we were not founded as a nation of
cowards yeah we were not founded as a
nation of ruler rule-followers because
lord knows King George gave a bunch of
rules and we didn't follow them yeah
we're a bunch of savages and we weren't
a bunch of anarchists and so the
question is what is left of the US and
what I horribly believe is that the tiny
number of people that we sort of
collected as our group are all that's
left of people who have the ability to
speak up after processing things and
finding our sense making architecture
completely insane and you can actually
begin to detect just how many there are
because the circle begins to close right
so that's true but the other thing is is
that we you know and I know that every
day I get letters and messages from
people who say thank god you're able to
speak I'm almost at the point where I
could say something but I know that I'm
gonna lose my job right and so the idea
is I know exactly what is keeping oh s
group of people from speak
it's it's one they don't feel like they
have any choice as in a presidential
candidate they're just gonna pick always
the the better of two terrible options
yeah and the second thing is is that
they can't afford to lose their jobs all
right so so I have started talking about
the first against the wall' Club which
in IDW style is named to be jarring and
the point is look I don't want to be
first against the wall but I'm aware of
a couple things I'm aware that one one
is not going to find stable safe haven
by placating them up there is no middle
ground you can sign up for the mob and
then we know what happens to you you
will be eaten in the end it will take
advantage of you and then at the point
where there are spoils to be divided all
hell's going to break loose for those
who are part of the mob the so-called
allies you can try to hedge right you
can try to make some concessions let's
try to stay look I don't know fan of
Brett Weinstein
however right I don't know that
everything that he says is wrong right
you can do something like that in which
case it'll come for you pretty soon yeah
or you can say screw it there's no safe
harbor to be had so I might as well say
the truth right I might as well say the
truth and what that means is they will
put me against the wall first I know
that right but I'm not willing to
compromise in order to be later against
the wall first against the wall if it's
gonna be again I don't like this at all
you don't I understand what you're doing
but my feeling about this is I'm not
intending to be against me either right
Oh either absolutely
[ __ ] the wall well we don't know what's
coming my point is don't hedge what why
are you hedging what sir it gives you
look let me make another argument
imagine that the US Army was being held
by 12 kids with a squirt gun yep
at some point somebody's got to walk
forward and take away a squirt gun from
a child is gonna bawl like a baby like
you remember what happened with the
Kathy Newman Jordan Peterson thing where
the idea is that they published this
thing that was supposed to make Jordan
look like an idiot and Kathy Newman
looked like a great interviewer in a
totally backfire because they didn't
understand what the what the read on it
was gonna be yep then people got angry
and then Kathy Newman said oh my god I
can't believe it people are coming after
me
well okay those are the same like much
better than people that you sick on
people every day
yeah so I think what my claim is is that
every time I conduct any kind of a poll
I can say please retweet this broadly
towards the people who are maximally
likely to disagree with it the number of
people supporting the supposed positions
of the commentariat yeah is tiny
nobody freakin likes this stuff
everybody hates it now that's too strong
no everybody is I mean look it's a
population versus individual level
analysis problem and as I keep saying to
people right the claims of this movement
are really really stupid
the strategy is incredibly smart and
that distinction is important it's not
like somebody wrote down the strategy
the strategy is more or less an evolved
strategy it's a borrowed strategy but it
is so sophisticated when it comes to
co-opting people who should know better
that really that's the thing you're
watching a kind of an organic well
preoptic so that's the kind of a word
that you'd use if you were privileged
enough to go to college okay
[Laughter]
yeah so here's the question we've got a
couple of puzzles that need to be solved
I'm just I'm just trying to evidence how
cheap it is to make an argument that
then you're supposed to spend 10 to 15
minutes falling over backwards and then
I feel I'm not privileged or that it
doesn't matter something yeah of course
you know what here's my thing okay I'm
male I'm
American I was born into a family that
had two cars in the garage okay so I'm
privileged as all hell and I'm also
correct deal with it deal with it yeah
no I'm of course of course we are both
on board with that look at your porcine
Hugh I'm gonna have to look that up your
figure out whether I neglected Pig like
you you're pink you're a person of color
bred person of you all right you can
pass this pink with you my guard I'm on
my garden okay um okay look we've got a
couple of problems one of the things
that I think is not well understood is
that there is something ultra dangerous
about the leaderless nature of this
movement there's a great place to start
when I come back from a visit with the
facilities hey folks welcome back we
have taken a brief break we have checked
in with events in the larger world and
we have decided that at least the first
step is very clear which is to start
drinking it Cheers all right so we are
facing a very interesting scenario in
the outside world and it is changing so
freaking fast that it is hard to even
know what to think and of course this is
very disorienting given how long we have
been watching this thing unfold and how
long it seemed somewhat limited to
college campuses maybe it was a bang and
then suddenly it's everywhere now
there's a lot to be said about what it
is and what it isn't really was never
limited to college campuses I think that
was the canard well it was limited to
college campuses in the sense that a lot
of what people could see was taking
place there don't believe it well
obviously I said to Congress this is not
a phenomenon of college campuses and
it's not a free speech yeah but it is
just I don't want to waste time
pretending that the majority is more
right than they are they're crazy and
they're wrong and it's clear they're
crazy and they're wrong and the part
that they had not clear they are not
updating yeah is that this is actually a
near-term threat to the Republic this is
beyond the Republic dude I just don't
even I know it's the West but at the
very least dude
we're in a nuclear I mean look part of
the problems you have the wrong guests
there are things that I cannot say I
cannot say that this is about George
Floyd because I'm on record for years
talking about the No Name revolution
yeah
I can't claim that this is about college
campuses because I've been talking about
this generally I can't claim that any of
this nonsense is true because I've named
this the twin nuclei problem if we find
out that this comes from the Wuhan lab
and then in fact it has to do with
research whether intentionally
weaponized or you know supposedly
defensive or who knows what we have
another nuclei left to go we're playing
these games on a nuclear planet and I
don't know what we're doing I have no
clue how people have the confidence that
everything is going to be fine because
it absolutely is not all going to be
fine automatically if it's fine it's
because people are going to make it fine
and people who are gonna make the people
who are gonna make it fine are the
people who are alarmed yeah the people
who understand how unfine it is and what
this trajectory does it right so I I
feel like we have an affirmative action
program for stupid people who happen to
be employed in academia political life
and the media we have to carry along
these stupid people and constantly tell
them how marvelous they are that they're
incrementally coming to understand this
when we should get rid of the lot of
them so Heather reminds me that there is
a a trope in the Hitchhiker's Guide
series in which those people are divided
for rocket they're on a different rocket
ship sent off what the rest of us coming
along we should give them all Pulitzer
Prizes all Nobel Prizes we should tell
them how very beautiful and prescient
they are and get them the [ __ ] off the
stage because they're idiots functional
they're gonna get us all killed they're
going to get us all killed and you know
the problem of saying I really don't
think George Stephanopoulos is the
of the analysis tree I don't think
Fareed Zakaria is got this thing wrapped
up I don't think Steven Pinker's
understood our moment it's like oh my
god how bitter and jealous and grass be
and grift it's like shut the [ __ ] up yes
just be quiet it's not well the problem
is we're up against a number of things
one the number of actual fundamental
thinkers is tiny well I think it's
bigger than you're claiming the number
of courageous ones I will say that Nance
right yeah so number of fundamental
thinkers is tiny the number of those
people who are courageous enough to say
anything is a tiny fraction of that and
what that leaves us with is very few
voices and we're all now in dialogue
with each other which you know is good
in one sense and I think dangerous in
another in the sense that to whatever
extent we have things wrong they we're
disappointing and they're worse no I'm
not kidding I'm very disappointed with
this a lot of the criticisms that they
lodged was like okay you know there's a
component of truth to that and you yeah
right exactly okay but but here's the
other thing that you know it's very easy
I think for those of us who get what's
going on to focus on those who are
driving it and the obvious components
here but I think there's some some
things that are accidently interfacing
with our moment that are very very
destructive today more so the leader
lessness leaderless ness is everywhere
our would-be leaders aren't at all
leader like they sort of you know the
question is do they look presidential
period right that's the question not are
they Presidential I don't care if they
look presidential if they know how to
behave in the frickin office but none of
them do so what we've got is a scenario
in which as I've said elsewhere we have
a very deep bench especially with
respect to black intellectuals we have a
very deep bench of people who are
courageous capable of leading but they
are all trapped in the gig economy you
and I are trapped in the gig economy all
the people who should be in positions of
leadership which would be frankly
crucial at this moment are trapped doing
something else
influencers and that influencer thing
has some relationship to being elite art
let me just ask you a question yeah you
have a place where people can contribute
to your and Heather's welfare yeah
what's a call patreon patreon yeah okay
is this thing on I hope so all right let
me be honest the key issue that I see is
getting people Fu money and one thing
that you can do if you can't speak is to
transfer your voice into Fu money to
people who can or who are at least
willing to go down with the ship
so one possibility is to get Bret and
Heather out of the gig economy and he
can't say this and he didn't know that I
was gonna say this because he also can't
stop me so in part I already found them
really can't you're by the way I looked
up Marsha Marsha Marsha very interesting
so one of the one of the issues is to
get the people that you love doesn't
have to be Bret and Heather out of the
gig economy by transferring a small
amount of your cash to people who are
risking everything for your benefit so
just FYI you can liberate people from
the gig economy if you want to and in
part the pocket of power of the purse
reigned supreme thanks I think that's a
good message and there are a lot of
people who are being courageous at this
moment this kind of crisis reveals who
they are and so pay close attention to
that and then we've got other who
impresses you in terms of courage well
let's given the centrality of well you
just mentioned black intellectuals let's
go through a few okay
I hope news Coleman Hughes Thomas
Chesterton Williams Chloe Valerie Dave
Chapelle though we both feel that he did
Chapelle topknot he just says that just
for a troubles us both a little bit yeah
but anyway still top of the list Camille
Foster Glenn Lowry community lkm y le k
MK m ele yes nailed it it's spelling
that's that's tough for both of us are
terrible but I think I'm better than you
yep John Wood jr. okay
did I say John McWhorter maybe no Glenn
Glenn Loury John McWhorter who have
teamed up for a very long time talking
about these issues Cornel West I would
say Cornel West yeah yeah I very much
appreciate brother Cornell yeah and I
really like his you know he is in some
ways pioneered IDW style stuff with
Robbie George and I really like that
team well the other thing is I don't
have to love everything these people do
I can just say that hey 70% good on you
yeah I'm fond of this guy hotep Jesus
there's some places where he's wrong but
I think he's got the basic stuff okay
anyway it's pretty good list all right
so that's the black intellectual is how
about non black you know like it's funny
it's this is harder actually I know yeah
well because weirdly the ability to
speak is partially based upon what your
intersectional points are yeah right and
so in some sense you would expect that
an underrated community which I would
say black intellectuals have been an
underrated community for not a short
time yep you wouldn't be surprised
Thomas solo might be one of these folks
yeah Thomas solo now of young people I
would say
Josephine mattias okay now let's talk
about non black intellectuals yeah who
impresses you particularly that's
younger younger well I really like Katy
Hertzog and I know her enough to dress
her um let's see young people why am i
drawing a blank
well I don't know I mean it's an
interesting question yeah
I'm gonna kick myself for the people I
know I must be forgetting but but who
the hell are they well you got a list I
thought that Melissa Chen talking about
Chinese issues on Joe Rogan as somebody
of Chinese extraction it was very
valuable yep because in part one of the
questions that we have is who's allowed
to say something based on their identity
points about some issue right so I'm
alarmed about the People's Republic of
China and the Chinese Communist Party
having as much influence as as it does
but I'm alarmed as a an Ashkenazi Jewish
person so gives you a lot less license
to talk about it well no it gives me
fine license to talk about it but in the
stoopid krazy world that we live in
publicly
nobody's look I want to talk about I
want to talk about mass insanity because
I honestly believe that as long as we
don't call it out as mass insanity
we've got a problem yeah and I agree it
is mass insanity and it has been labeled
as literally a religious movement which
it has many of those components it
really the - forgiveness half -
forgiveness indeed all right so we've
struck out you know
Katie's not that young she's young yes
but she's not that young but we've more
or less struck yeah I don't know what
about onihachi bread scare podcast I
don't think I know her and I don't know
Dasha her co-hosts as well as I as I
might but they're pretty courageous and
you know in part I think you know what
we have to talk about is the fact that
this is within a universality class
which we're data matters and lived
experiences down sort of down regulated
because it's too easy to say well you
know my cousin Jim you know had a
problem with the police and therefore
yeah yeah yeah right oh it's anecdote at
the same time we've got an attack on
stem to prevent us from correcting for
the inning well that's true but and then
we also have the problem that there's
certain issues that are invisible to us
first so for example I was talking to
this guy Mike Rasheed who is a
bodybuilder and a heavyweight boxer who
has done time in
Arizona prison and his point to me was
you don't understand that the situation
with George Floyd is is that many of us
feel that we're good people who've been
pushed through desperation to bat it in
violent actions oh I fully believe this
I family the lived experience stuff my
feeling about it is that we could learn
from it if people stopped invoking it as
a counter to statistics they are taking
honest energy right there we have been
staving off the French Revolution right
right we've been staving it off for a
generation or more and in staving it off
the pressure has built up and it is now
spilled into the streets and it has been
captured by people whose plans are not
smart and not on earth well and this is
this issue which is that we have a group
of people who are deaf to the claim that
there's a a problem with race and
policing and criminal justice and
prosecution and all of this stuff
that's on one side and then then another
group of people that don't want to look
at any statistics because the lived
experience Trump's everything yeah and
the key point is both of these are
problematic yep but the right thing to
do is to use the lived experience as an
intuition pump for what it is I should
be asking as a question and then go
gather statistics about that right to
show that in fact the lived experience
point it's a little bit like ethno
pharmacology where okay so maybe there's
an Amazonian tribe that tells the story
about you know the flower God coming and
and and clearing us of our demons or
something or whatever and you're
supposed to say actually I'm not going
to discount that I'm gonna use that as
I'm gonna go find the molecule that's
responsible for the thing you just told
me the myth about Amen why can't we yeah
why can't we figure this out I know
stupid because like obviously ethnic
pharmacology we're talking about
genius-level people in the Amazon right
but I don't want to pretend that I have
to believe in the flower God in order to
understand what they figured out right I
mean frankly this is as close as taking
ayahuasca because ayahuasca is an
improbable combination of molecules that
has an utterly
unag normal effect you want to say
things about the two components I don't
I don't know that I could say very much
I mean I know a little but well you
basically you have you have this DMT
molecule which is a highly
hallucinogenic you have an MAOI molecule
it comes from a different plant and
these people figured out that combine it
these two plants combined together have
it which how did they figure this out
how do they figure it out and how do you
know in a you know an environment where
everything is so freaking toxic how
exactly run the experiments together
genius there's some genius whose name we
don't know yeah right or a composite
genius over generations did whatever it
had whatever it the point is there's not
a college it's not like a bunch of
morons accidentally stumbled on
ayahuasca right and then you get but the
fact that they chose to tell a myth
about how ayahuasca acts because they
didn't have access to the pathway like
I'm not gonna sit there prostrate right
you know bowing down to the Amazonian
genius my feeling is okay
these geniuses ran this portion of the
relay race now it's our turn to do our
our genius stuff on top of yep and we've
got the perfect tools to do it and to
shut down those tools at this moment
amen and the idea that I can't have this
conversation or anywhere it drives me
nuts yeah well yes so we have a very
small crowd of people who are ready for
this so if we don't have very many on
the list of young we have huge numbers
of people who are who have somebody
else's hands around their throat yes
they do and because we've sometimes
those hands are China sometimes those
hands are the commentariat sometimes
those hands are people who are trying to
keep an illusion going because they you
know like a every University is a fraud
all right I want to try to rescue my
idea of the first against the wall club
because I think this is important so I
am starting the first against the wall
club and the point of this is not that I
want to be first against the wall I
better not be I want to avoid being
against the wall but because there is no
safe harbor if you become an ally of
this thing you will last until you are
no longer useful to it and then they
will go after you if you try to placate
it by saying
half-truths then it will come after you
pretty soon the only thing the only
valuable position that I see is speaking
the truth and accepting the consequences
and the reason that I think this is
important is that I know from experience
that people have to stare into the abyss
in order to find their courage and so
there's some process I think it takes
for people who have it in them maybe a
couple of weeks a couple of weeks of
thinking holy crap is that really am I
do I accept that is there something else
to do and then you get used to it
you come to understand that okay that is
not the fate I want but I'm willing to
accept the possibility of that fate in
order not to suffer this other fate and
one of the fates that you don't want to
suffer is losing your ability to speak
obvious truths look I I understand the
counterintuitive branding concept which
is what I did with IDW but I don't like
it
I know I know and it's not but you know
maybe it's genius maybe the idea is I
don't like it because it's genius
I don't know it's the abyss there are a
lot of people right there are a lot of
people who are gonna have your initial
reaction I'll be honest with you can I
tell you what I hate about it yeah okay
I hate about it I don't think these guys
on the other side of this are that
bigger that good it's not the guys you
have to watch this thing spread across
people I'm sorry I just I really believe
that honestly we've so I coined this
phrase the Chihuahua effect for a tiny
number of people terrorizing a large
number of people bite barking so loud
and so often I get it except I've also
seen oh wait a second yeah let's talk
about a very difficult principle how do
you tell a black person who has
submitted a wrong answer on their
mathematics that they're wrong
you mark it wrong you're wrong
yeah how do you tell an indigenous
American whose land has been effectively
stolen by white invaders that they're
wrong about a multiplication problem
I'm guessing it's somewhat similar it
sounds the same you're wrong you're
wrong I think that this is a ritual that
we have to actually go through which is
I want you to imagine the least
fortunate person in the world making a
mathematical error and I want you to
practice a very simple exercise out of
compassion and love so that that person
can get better and not be deluded that
their oppression is equivalent to their
being correct I want you to think about
loving that person more than you than
you do right now and telling that person
what they need to hear yeah you're wrong
that's that's what respect sounds like
respect sounds like you're wrong you're
wrong
yeah I am back in 2017 may or may not
remember I tweeted that all else being
equal 50% of the time that a man and a
woman disagree about a matter that is
factual the man will be right all else
being there's no evidence I I don't know
male who's ever won this argument well
nice try it's all you coming next
gong long yep all right so no no but
this is is it joke one of the problems I
have with women is telling them that
they're wrong yeah it's not easy which
is like here's the Equality that you've
been asking for right
Sal you know that you know you know that
point about your projections when you
say 3% you don't multiply three times
the number you multiply 0.03 yeah you're
wrong but you know what I love I love
the women who get this and understand
that it is it is respect it is it is yes
maybe the male idiom but at the point is
actual equality involves taking that
part of the male idiom and acquiring we
even good at it that's some level you
and Heather are collaborators yeah he
and I are collaborators hundred percent
I fight for every goddamn point that I
get right when I when I savagely
win one of these points I take a [ __ ]
victory left because it's hard to beat
him oh yeah alright so the point was
leadership hmm because of its absence is
creating a lethal hazard were the energy
yeah the French Revolution energy that
has spilled into our streets to have
proper leaders smart cogent people right
right they could shut down the value are
their leaders no you sure
well I'm not saying that there's nobody
in that role but I'm saying when I look
at them I'm saying that they don't want
to be leaders right now tiller Mike yeah
made a very clear bid for being the
leader in Atlanta you did Dave Chappelle
made a bid by saying I don't want to be
the leader
I trust the street that guy is not
stupid well that was a bid for later
leadership that was Gary B I actually
think that in Dave Chappelle's case he
is suffering from the same thing that
those of us who are more tuned in at a
daily level are suffering which is the
Edit on our raw data yeah he's really
bad I don't think that that was the
final word of Dave Chappelle oh I don't
think so either
I think the Dave Chappelle bought
himself a huge ton of credibility with
the street well I hope so because if
Dave Chappelle emerges as leader I've
suddenly am in a position to breathe a
great sigh of relief if I had to
conjecture yeah I'm not am i right that
you and I both have a very high
estimation of Dave Chappelle from
intellectually from the minute my belief
is that comedy is a weird game it is
weirdly meritocratic they laugh or they
don't laugh well I would say differently
the comedians have a different
understanding of the ranking the
comedian's have a well-crafted joke
rubric that is everybody understands
that
Gallagher used to be able to get laughs
but in general he
wasn't seen as being the top of the
comedic pile because he was a prop comic
except I'm not positive the Dave
Chappelle was using this appearance to
establish his credibility and that his
later act will actually be the one
that's important so I'm gonna just I'm
gonna plant that flag perfect okay I'd
love that to be true because this was
disappointing if that's all there is yes
and it was conspicuous right so in some
sense it does leave the question about
what comes later you know the the length
of it the way in which it appeared all
sorts of things about interesting he
personalized it so he said I was born at
8:46 in the morning and it was a minute
46 seconds on this guy's neck yeah
George Floyd's neck and he also did some
other stuff with his birthday and he
talked about this in terms of his father
calling for his mother on his deathbed
and the mother being close to slavery
and it's not that far in our rearview
mirror it was a masterful construction
which did not like you know there's this
weird thing about Strauss II and
communication when you see a person who
you respect as much as I think both of
us respect Dave Chappelle intellectually
not using all neurons available I'm
loathe to think that he's thinking this
through less than we are and I'm
inclined to think that he's thinking
this thing through more than me well I
don't disagree with that and so you'll
you'll respect that my hypothesis about
what's going on is that he encountered
data that did not allow him to look well
would be one possibly this is that he
was using very high-level heuristics
right on the data he got but I think
that in part you see despite the fact
that I think that we redirected all of
the kovat energy towards George Floyd
and policing and all of the economic
energy with the sky high unemployment
towards George Floyd policing I think
that there was another thing that's
being said to us which is not being said
literally
which is we've been waiting for a long
time to get rid of the specter that is
the invisible racism that we feel but
cannot pinpoint oh yeah and I saw him in
part glom on to that oh yeah I agree and
so this is very frustrating she's like
maybe maybe we the black community are
gonna hijack some energy that wasn't
ours but on the other hand you've
hijacked [ __ ] for so long oh there's a
lot of this that actually the
frightening thing is if you take [ __ ]
that the black community has put up with
has simply put up with because it had no
choice right and you turn it around it
looks a lot like this but the problem is
the this issue of oppression reversing
right instead of ending oppression
turning the tables in the press right
but the problem is the republic will not
survive that reversal in other words the
republic could tolerate the unfairness
to black people
it was completely unjust and
unacceptable and on american but it was
not fatal turning the tables of this
oppression well we'll be quickly
finished yeah you don't even mean what
you just said because i know you very
well
it was fatal at the level of it betrayed
the ideals of the republic no even if
the republic was viable it was viable as
a non serious entity in a weird way
right which is why right i am so upset
at the slogan mega yeah because the
point is that last a if again yes it's
the again if you are in one of the
populations for which America was never
great this is a finger in the eye right
right and so my feeling is look I'm not
signing on to that goddamn slogan even
though I would love for America to be
great and I am proud of what America is
in many regards I cannot sign on to that
[ __ ] second a unless you take care of
everybody are they not Americans well
you know it's a more devious slogan than
that I mean I really appreciate that
you've been on this since the beginning
and I think it's a good call I guess the
idea is that there are ways in which
America was once great that it needs to
be great again
yeah and there
ways in which America has never been
great in which case it needs to become
great for the first time and new yeah
and so the issue is there is America to
be made great again yeah and there is
America that has never been great and
needs to be made great for the first
time and that make America great again
is one of these perfectly ambiguous
slogans designed to be work designed to
be a Rorschach test yeah exactly right
it's designed app and so you know my
feeling about this is it's it's worse
than you're saying because it's cleverer
than you're saying
no I agree with that actually but and by
the way people don't know this and I've
never really gotten this out but when I
went to meet with Kanye which was put
into Barry Weiss's calm article times
peace yeah right I was not happy about
her talking about that nor was I happy
talking about the Candice Owens and
Candice Owens was my entree on to Kanye
my entire focus was what were we going
to do with mega the slogan when Trump
was gone right and then in essence we
were you know as Scott Adams I think
maybe popularized like one screen
multiple movies or two movies who was it
who is going to give us a common picture
of Magha and the hope was the Kanye
who's a different kind of genius an
artistic genius but not necessarily a
political one yeah was the person who
would have had the highest likelihood of
getting us onto the same page when the
idea is that somebody had come up with a
slogan which functioned as the dress if
you recall is it black and blue or white
and gold and that was the hope that the
hope was that Kanye was the only guy in
the country who could actually speak and
do the Obama 360 trick so Obama in his
affirmative action speech walked around
affirmative action
and let everyone know that he could see
their viewpoint uh-huh well I see it I
mean I Kayne didn't have that skill in
my opinion not because he wasn't
artistically gifted but because it
required a different skill set well yeah
we know it didn't happen
I think his embrace of Candace was a
particular problem because Candace is a
special entity well this is different
her purposes not black facing its white
face well can Candace is a very
complicated or was a very complicated
object that chose to simplify in a
particular direction which was
unfortunate you saw what she did where
she pulled back with Sam Harris when she
and sam Harris were on different sides
of an issue so I got a tremendous amount
of guff for pointing to Candace as
somebody who was building bridges behind
the scenes why would she even vited me
who disagreed with her on politics to a
meeting with Kanye very often we had
this problem that somebody actually
builds bridges in private and burns them
in public because red meat pays the
bills yeah but they're actually playing
multiple roles ben shapiro would be
another example of this is somebody who
quite honestly is often looking to
repair things in private but it has a
business to attend to which is pointing
out what the problems are with the other
side yeah the thing about Candace though
I mean it's possible I'm just wrong
about her yeah but I don't know I've
been I've been in the same place with
Candace from the beginning of her rise
agreed right I mean I don't think you've
changed positions and you've seen what
was positive and what she was doing and
your point was is that she will do to
the positive which should not be done to
the positive because she will mangle
whatever it is that she can see that
could be positive with the negative of
the red meat and I don't think you've
been wrong about yeah so far I haven't
seen a break in the story it's all
divided by the same function but anyway
you know interesting that Dave Chappelle
called her out in his day I wasn't
thrilled in how he did it but but
nonetheless it was very funny he said
Wow
the most beautiful and intelligent way
to say the dumbest things possible yeah
well that was the nice part of what he
said
but anyway you know I feel like we've
lost track and we're gonna have to wrap
this up we're gonna lose our light well
what is it Bret let me just ask you you
have our open-ended thing we've been at
this we've gotten a tremendous amount of
attention if people wanted to know that
we're here they know that we're here
something is going wrong yeah and it am
I correct that we could blow up the
entire planet we could find ourselves in
a nuclear war over the breakdown of
civil society shared meaning shared
understanding yeah we are about to torch
all of humanity potentially over very
weird issues like do you understand and
feel my pain it's and if you look at the
prescriptions that we've been handed as
to what those who are advancing this a
should be done next it is almost like we
are being told that the ship we are on
is flawed and if only we sink it a
better one will come and it's just not
right have you read an essay called ship
of fools a short story by one Theodore
Kaczynski I have not read the short
story I didn't read the manifesto short
story is about a ship on which there's a
cabin boy their first mates there's a
female passenger Mexicans and everybody
on board
is arguing about homosexuals aren't
being treated properly the women aren't
being treated properly the Mexicans
aren't being treated properly and the
cabin boy keeps saying we are sailing
into an iceberg field and they keep
having the same arguments over and over
again and then at the end spontaneously
and the ship hit an iceberg and sank and
all hands were lost yep that's about
where we are
so don't love quoting the Unabomber well
I will tell you that inside of academia
something very interesting happened with
the Unabomber which is that we all
understood that he was crazy and a small
number of highly intellectual people
looked at his manifesto anyway the point
was actually some of the manifest it was
perfectly juvenile right it was not high
quality work
not on some of it some was insightful
some of it was insightful and this is
partially the problem that a man driven
half-mad through a partial insight and I
should say that he blew off the hand of
our mutual acquaintance david glenn
tanner yep
and so David Lerner who I think is a
great guy and misunderstood and Ted
Kaczynski's the son of a [ __ ] yeah
agree right so now we now we've said the
things that needed to be said yeah but
there was insight they're smart people
including dick Alexander we're not so
quick to dismiss the manifesto wholesale
well in part you would expect somebody
with a partial version of the truth to
be driven insane yes very much so
especially if isolated from others
especially if it was it hard to see and
hurt he was early yeah okay so let us
say there's plenty more complement what
yeah what is to get out kids you title
all right well folks I have advanced a
plan for starting to fix this in
November check out Joe Rogan's clip
channel for the Dark Horse duo strategy
Dark Horse's the podcast but with the
podcast it's Dark Horse with the H
capitalized to the Dark Horse duo is not
really about the Dark Horse podcast it's
about the idea of Dark Horse's
which has a long and storied history
relative to presidential candidates so
it's almost an accident that the two of
them line up but check out the clip and
I think that this is the best plan we've
got short term now the deepest plan we
have this is a split ticket it's not
even a split ticket so one of the things
I have learned in decades now of
thinking about how to fix civilization
is that there's certain things you can't
afford you can't afford a constitutional
convention and you can't afford a
revolution so you have to work within
the structure you've got but you have to
think creatively about how to make the
structure that you've got how would I
get a functional revolution without a
physical road yeah we need revolutionary
change without revolution and so the
idea is I'm in agreement with that part
of it okay
and I also believe that it cannot be
Trump versus Biden canopy Trump versus
bite in fact now that we are in kovat
and George Floyd riots
territory and we've got these two is
your strategy to pressure Biden to step
back no it'll be one way but I don't
think that'll happen because I think we
know what the DNC is really about so I
don't I think they will go down with the
ship rather than allow I no I don't
think with these style of demonstrations
that that is something that I want to
give away just you well I agree maybe
they're steering time to ask for both of
these people to retire because they're
too old to set in their ways too limited
going downhill fast Jesus and Trump
versus Biden you have a seventy-year-old
versus like it's a ferry 74 year old
versus a 77 year old we've never had
anything remotely look like that in
American history yeah it's preposterous
I mean let me just advance an idea that
you should be expected to live 20 years
with the consequences of your actions I
like that I like that a lot
you should be expected to live 20 years
of the consequences of your actions so
that you have you take responsibility
for them rather than and I don't think
94 and 97 are expectations if I looked
at a life table from an insurance
company for these two gentlemen
particularly not with cognitive problems
I see in them both yeah
right and that's before you get to their
moral failings which are apparent in
both cases so I mean off the stage yeah
but nonetheless if they won't leave the
stage we have to usher them off the
stage
so in short check out that clip on Joe
Rogan's clip channel the short version
is we draft to people who have three
characteristics in common the
characteristics are they are patriotic
they are courageous and they are capable
one of them has to come from the
center-left one of them has to come from
the center-right so that they dislike
their wings more than they dislike the
loyal opposition across the aisle right
and decency will cause them to rule in
our favor to govern in our favor now
here's the thing we draft the two of
them they flip a coin to decide which
one is top of ticket but the agreement
is that they govern by consensus except
in two cases the two cases are cases
where there's no time for dual
decision-making and the other case is
that they can't resolve something in
which case somebody has to make a call
and that's the person who inhabits the
room you agree this is a Hail Mary no
at this point I think we the Democrats
and Republicans have surprisingly
fumbled the ball so badly that they have
in fact yeah but you should be looking
for is something near violence in the
streets no I'm not kidding
right every peaceful demonstration is a
demonstration of potential violence
people don't understand this right yeah
right it's a it's a bit it's a
convertible threat it's a convertible
threat and in our case we have the
threat in the street and then we have a
threat that we can all infer comes from
the hills well why I was so upset about
the looting because it's like you can't
even keep your sword in its sheath in
order to communicate power yeah where
did you learn violence right it's very
low grade wasteful so anyway we've got
we've got a potential civil war on our
hands which could be the uninvent of
America very quickly so is it a Hail
Mary no because I you know I will tell
you I unveiled this idea first on my own
podcast which has a moderate following
but I haven't gotten a single negative
reaction which I find interesting I
think people are finally aware that all
of the explanations of what is and isn't
possibly the easiest thing to say is no
trump no Biden yeah
no Trump no Biden is a strategy yep
which is get these two old white
maladapted has Ben's off the goddamn
national and world stage period the end
don't send me any like if you think
about 2024 yeah the rules that say you
are not allowed to participate in an
event that we aren't behind and we're
gonna pick the New York Times and CNN
and all the NPR to host the debates yeah
there is no primary there's no primary
at all there's no democracy it's like
right it's they were in inventing
America and now the street is about to
uninvent America and you know roughly
speaking as much as I decry the stupid
use of violence it's time for pitch
it's time you know I've said this on
glass I said I said this on Rogan it's
time to revolt yes
but the problem is is that you've got a
revolt better yes you're not a revolt
better you know it can't all be about
policing from some terrible thing that
happened in Minneapolis and it can't be
about policing where you think the smart
reaction is to abolish the police rather
than make them unnecessary by some means
right you can't do it this way so okay
you and I agree in fact I've been saying
defeat Trump Biden in 2020 defeat Trump
Trump Biden in 2020 so we've got this
plan I have proposed to people it
doesn't have to be these two people but
I think they are viable and that they
were the key thing is to get Trump and
Biden to understand that we don't like
you
yeah and that we only voted for Trump to
get rid of Hillary you know I I talked
about the old lady who swallowed a fly
and I know a young I know a young nation
that voted a trump right it's good
Hillary to bump they voted at Trump
right and so the idea is like I don't
want to swallow a series of crazier and
crazier people to get rid of the last
crazy person we have a ton of competent
good decent people people who serve in
our military yep people who devote their
life to public service and we need to
draft them and we in my write that it's
an imperative that whoever is put into
power should be dead on arrival as far
as the RLC in DNC oh yes like
unacceptability to the gym those two
entities don't hate you you're not good
enough for us it doesn't mean that
you're good if they hate you right it is
a necessary condition that they and the
RNC should find you to be reprehensible
childlike possessed of insane ideas yeah
and the idea is like goddamn these two
houses right a pox on both your houses
now here's the thing there is also as
terrifying as this is there is also the
following possibility implied here that
come November yeah we could feel better
we could be headed towards something
that looked to everybody like leadership
of a kind we have not seen in
decades for sure it makes sense
good luck with that and with the Dark
Horse pocket with the dark floors of
podcast which has come to an end as a
result of failing light and a need to
move on to other things but we will be
back so thanks everybody for watching
and thank you Eric for joining us thanks
Matthew little do this again soon
all right [ __ ] the poor dude all right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]